foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
did you trust the Supreme Court
I don't know many that did
I can't tell you if there's anyone who
actually dressed the Supreme Court is
there in this country I mean they're
cheering the supreme court this morning
the fascist and the bigots
they love this
ah if you if you go look at Charlie
Kirk's Ben Shapiro Matt Walsh's page oh
yeah they are [__] just excited
about their supremacist Court
this is Trump's courts by the way
I don't know if you know that
elections have consequences as they say
and this is a huge consequence
huge
consequence
of not engaging in your democracy and
participating
in your democracy and participating in
elections that's what this is
you don't have to point fingers to any
certain group
the finger points back at ourselves
we're responsible for democracy rather
we vote or not
and we're responsible for the outcomes
of democracy whether we vote or not
we are the people
Tony are you blaming it on us we make up
the country folks
now we're in a situation where the minor
minority ideology
is ruling with power
but it's not democracy
it's not democracy
because what they want is oligarchy
what they want is plutocracy and what
they want is theocracy
which only leads to the minority in
power
and controlling the majority
of what they do what they say where they
go where they don't who they love who
they don't
who they want to marry who they want to
be how they want to dress what religion
or if they want religion
when you when you rule with oligarchy
when you rule with theocracy when you
rule with plutocracy with the few
because trust me this is the few listen
I don't know if you remember what
happened last year during the decisions
of the Supreme Court there was one in
particular that stands out in my mind
which is Roe v Wade and overturning
Women's Health Care Banning it in this
country and the Republicans going balls
deep and demanding Women's Health Care
from state to state to state
making it criminal for women to receive
Health Care
even going to a state where it's legal
to receive that Health Care
and now this morning they they the
theocracy the plutocracy the oligarchy
believes
that these Supreme Court decisions which
they bought and paid for folks they
bought and paid for this
they believe
that these decisions are going to bring
them the country that they want
the platocracy the theocracy the
oligarchy that they so desire
much more than democracy
I have a feeling and it's just a feeling
it kind of has the same stench
when they overturned Roe v Wade and
we're really excited about it
even in Kansas
they said oh you're gonna take our
rights to Health Care away I don't think
so
[__] you on a referendum
I don't know I don't know if you know
this
but most average working Americans
because they've been lied to about
higher education in this country for
decades and decades and decades and I
believe that's the truth
is that we've been lied to
just get you a college degree and you'll
be one of us
go get in debt wink
let us put the heel of oligarchy and
plutocracy on your [__] head do it
you won't get to be one of us if you
don't
and now and now I I
I don't have more to explain this is
[__] weird it's weird as [__] because
this Supreme Court case was brought it
started here in Missouri in my own state
with an attorney general who is now a
United States Senator
it's the wildest [__] I'll ever I
and again I give you a this example over
and over and over again for people vote
based on affiliation
we have to [__] slap them in the face
and wake them up and realize that
they're voting against their own
interest yes that is I don't give a [__]
what anyone tells you uh they're not
really yes they are
you walk around in Missouri and ask them
if they give a damn who someone marries
they'll tell you no if they if you ask
them if they want recreational marijuana
then it bothers them if there is they'll
say I don't give a [__] there was a
referendum about it
if you ask most most missourians that
have student debt like oh you're you're
gonna let the federal government forgive
my debt yeah that's cool with me
you know what's crazy
those same [__]
voted
for a guy to be the United States
senator who is the most anti-marijuana
[__] out there and he's the one
he's the attorney general who initiated
this case to stop
them from getting that student debt
relief
using Mohela the state organization who
is federally funded to collect federal
debt
as an excuse
now it seems the White House and the
Biden Administration are not going to
lay down on this one and I doubt they
lay down on discriminating against gay
people and businesses because folks
that's where we're at
they're gonna put up signs that say
Gay's not allowed
it's you're gonna see it you're gonna
see it doubt me doubt me you
[__] doubt me
because this wasn't about freedom of
speech this wasn't about student debt
these decisions and them cheering about
it is about legalizing hate
just like yesterday with it when they
struck down affirmative action
on College admissions it's about
legalizing hate that's why they [__]
love Trump
they don't love him because he's smart
they don't love him because he's good
they love him because he lets them be
the worst version of themselves
that's why they love him
until you come to that realization you
will not understand why they keep
following him in a cult-like manner
human beings are a funny species
we're I mean you know how hard it is to
be a good person
do you know how much will power and how
much work it takes to be a good person
I know I'll get trashed for this but
it's difficult
you really gotta work against your own
nature
to be a good human and there's so few of
us out there that are good humans I'm
not I'm I don't consider myself in the
good category
I try to be
humans are flawed by Nature
it's what actually makes us [__]
human
what do you think we evolved to this
state
because we were so good
we were such a perfect species no Jesus
Christ look at these [__] [__] we
got running around Rhonda santis Donald
Trump Matt Walsh
Ben Shapiro
Nick Fuentes
Kanye West we have these [__] flawed
shitty human beings running around all
around us
and we're supposed to be the perfect
species we are not
I don't know what perfect exist now
there are a few good ones of us humans
out there genuine good I mean just they
don't have to work hard to be good
but it's a heavy lift
it's a heavy lift it's worth it
democracy is worth it
trying trying to understand someone
else's life experience is worth it
knowing that just because you aren't
affected doesn't mean others aren't
empathy is a hell of a thing to get
humans to feel
this is why the snowball into
authoritarianism is dangerous
this is why the snowball into legalizing
hate is so dangerous
why it's so dangerous to put someone as
our leader who allows us to be the worst
version of ourselves
this is what happens
I hate to tell you but the email lady
was right
it's not that they're all deplorable
it's that they want to be deplorable
they want to be so badly
and he allowed them to be deplorable he
gave them the permission he gave them
the space
to be bigots racist
misogynist
selfish
unempathetic
and absolutely garbage humans
and not only that they legitimized
their stance
by placing illegitimate illegitimate
Supreme Court Justices as far as I'm
concerned
now a lot of people are yelling and
screaming pack the courts this morning
well we're gonna have to give a hell of
a lot of support to pack the courts
folks
I told you yesterday this the courts
aren't going to save us
the Congress the Senate the presidency
isn't going to save us
from ourselves only we the people can do
this
us
we are a collective we are a society we
are a nation
it is us the people
we are coming up
on Independence Day
freedom
freedom [__]
in the Supreme Court of the United
States
just told poor people
and gay people go get [__]
you could take your [__] Liberty and
your freedom and stick it up your
[__] ass
because we don't think you got it
if you ain't got no money [__] you
if you're part of a certain type of
community because of who you are [__]
you
[__] you and your Independence you don't
get it
your second class
mark it down
the question is are you gonna remember
this
that's the question are you going to
remember this
here we are June 30th
June 29th yesterday with the affirmative
action decision
in 2023
we have to carry the water of democracy
here the the pro-democracy Coalition we
have to do our job and politicizing this
issue
mark my words they're not done
they're not done
if you think the Supreme Court decisions
today and yesterday are the end of it oh
well they got up man
they're good now
they're good now they don't have
affirmative action in college admissions
they don't have to serve gay people and
buy God those poor people can go [__]
themselves when it comes to student debt
so we're good we don't We're Not Gonna
We're not gonna try anything else we're
not going to try to roll this snowball
any you're full of [__]
these fascists won't stop here
there's gonna be all kinds all kinds of
State legislation
you don't think there's going to be
State legislation in these red states to
double down on discriminating against
gay people the lgbtq community
you don't think
you don't think these states are going
to use their religions to discriminate
to pass bills to make sure that
affirmative action is smashed everywhere
not just in college admissions
huh
you believe that
you really think that these states
aren't going to double down on student
debt
and put their foot on the [__] heads
of middle class and lower class broke
Americans who are living paycheck to pay
paycheck even though they did the thing
that they told them to do and go to
college and you'll be successful you'll
be one of us you'll be rich
you don't think they're gonna double
down you don't know them very [__]
well then
and if this morning you're waking up and
you're pissed off I don't care who you
are or where you're from or who you
voted for in the past if you're pissed
off about student debt there is only one
[__] only one [__] to
blame
Republicans any of them all of them
every one of those [__]
I don't care if they come out and
they're like this is a bad decision well
then switch parties then
blame it on them and if you don't see if
you don't see the anti-populist populism
here you are F you are [__] out of
your mind
do you have any idea how excited the
Bernie Bros are this morning that Joe
Biden is going to become dark Brandon on
this [__] student debt relief
they've made Joe Biden into a hero for
socialist
and leftist that's right
they're gonna turn him into the hero
the White House vowing not to [__]
stop
they shouldn't
and to think to think
this is what pisses me off about tyt and
all these [__] just [__] box leftists
out there
who are helping Trump when they knock on
Biden because he's old he's been in
politics too long get the [__] out of
here how do you think that guy already
has a contingency plan ready
experience
he's one of the most experienced
presidents we've had in government in
the history of our country you stupid
[__]
think about who he is
and think about how he's had been able
to accomplish what he has
and if it weren't for republicans
millions of Americans today millions of
Americans today would not have a [__]
student loan statement
that that is ten thousand dollars more
today than what it was yesterday
that's right
if it weren't for republicans
Eric Schmidt the former Attorney General
of Missouri now a United States Senator
because Missouri is blind to affiliation
oh man I just vote Republican I don't
give a [__] what happens
we have to shake the weeds
we have to we have we have to pull out
this bushes by The Roots
we have to change the landscape folks
I know a lot of people think populism is
dangerous
authoritarian populism is really [__]
really dangerous
rather it's on the left or the right
it's what leads to populations
in countries being exterminated
but when populism is backed by the
majority and a democracy
it is not
people in this country don't want you to
[__] tell us who we can love
rather we're [__] gay straight
lesbian trans doesn't matter we do not
want you the government you [__]
scumbag big government Republicans we
don't want you to tell us who the [__]
we can love
or anyone else who the [__] they can
love
we don't want you to settle Us big
government with piles and piles and
piles and mountains of debt
that keep the [__] foot of Oppression
on us for our entire lives with saddling
us with debt
attached with the federal government
Congress dictates the [__] interest
rate
this is federal debt
us it's our tax dollars so when when is
Marjorie Taylor green going to be forced
to pay back her PPP loans huh
those are federal [__] loans
she didn't deserve those and earned
those [__] her I want my money [__]
I want my money
when when are we going to demand
that the PPP loans forgiven we get our
money back
if they can demand it from every
middle-class American who took out a
student loan because their parents
weren't [__] part of the oligarchy in
this country then yeah we want our
[__] money back
now
not tomorrow not the next day right now
and we want it with interest
matter of fact since interest rates are
going up let's make it 15 to 20 percent
it's time
I'm telling you I know you think it's
not true
but the majority of Americans are not
going to be on the side of these
decisions
Americans do not trust the Supreme Court
they don't trust them or maybe it's a
question Americans trust the Supreme
Court
Americans don't trust the Supreme Court
it's a warning
but it's up to you
it's your job
you can't just tweet
you're we're not going to Tweet our ways
out of this
you can't just repost something on
Facebook We're Not Gonna repost our
social media way out of this you can't
just go make a [__] tick tock
it's not gonna work
the pro-democracy Coalition has to find
commonality and it's right here
it's right now this is the bridge
we can disagree on a lot of [__] [__]
Joe Biden's age socialism
Universal Health Care Free College we
can debate a lot of [__]
but we ain't gonna get to debate [__]
don't you get it
we ain't gonna get to debate [__] if we
don't do our job
and our job is to engage
participate in our democracy
yell scream talk to your [__]
neighbors your friends your family the
people at the peep ta the people at your
church the people are standing in line
at the grocery store
tell them
I'm telling you the majority are on your
side
in these Supreme Court decisions
you think there's gonna be a [__] ton of
people you're [__] cheering
about this Supreme Court decision on
student debt
uh you are stupid [__] if you believe
being excited about this student debt
decision that you're in the majority you
are a dumb [__]
that is not a populist message
at all not even [__] close
not even close
that's why Joe Biden
has done such a magnificent job
and I know you say well Tony he didn't
get it done
think about the politics think about how
he's moving our politics
think about how he's moving the
messaging in the narrative in this
country because he has one Focus
one one man date
and yes I know it's hard to believe that
he's stuck to it this whole time but I
believe he has
his mandate is to the American people
not to the oligarchy not to the
theocracy
not to the plutocracy
but to the people
can he do it all himself no he needs us
and it doesn't matter who the president
is
it doesn't matter they need us
they have to have our voice they have to
have our action
it is imperative
that we talk about this over this
holiday weekend
everywhere you go
every person you run into
there's going to be very few no matter
where you live in this country
that are going to tell you [__] that
stupid dead
there's gonna be very few
because not only do they may have
student debt
they may have someone they know
their friends their family their child
their grandchild
who was saddled with this debt
it would make a huge difference in their
life
and now that we've been months and
months and months and months with
Republicans forcing this issue
forcing Americans to [__] sweat
whether this is going to happen or not
because it would make a huge difference
in their lives now we're at the now
we're at a Breaking Point
and the Administration has signaled this
morning they're not going to back down
on this
I don't know exactly what their plan is
but we'll see we'll see if what they've
got can deliver
but we have to have a plan We the People
we have to band together in a coalition
to say no to these Supreme Court
decisions like we said no to them in
2022 last year after Roe v Wade was
overturned
we have to tell them no on striking down
affirmative action we have to tell them
no on on legalizing hate against gay
people in businesses
when they're trying to make it to where
businesses can discriminate against the
lgbtq community
and we have to tell them no the
Americans want the student debt relief
from the federal government we are the
federal government It Is Us
and we say yes
to the administration's decision
to forgive that debt and if we can't get
that debt forgived we want our PPP money
back
with interest High interest too so pay
up Marge pay up you [__] [__] oh baby
I'm hot today let me tell you something
it's good thing that I'm hot today it's
a good damn thing I'm hot today because
today is our last show till next
Thursday because we are going to be off
Monday Tuesday Wednesday for that
holiday where you're going to be out and
about telling people about scotus and
what the [__] they need to do to
participate in their democracy which is
blaming all on one [__] the
Republican party don't go anywhere we're
gonna be hot right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product hard and blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
who's ready to bring the [__] deep
the fireworks Freedom the independence
of Liberty in this kind of shitty thank
you
[Music]
Patriot week
they [__] all over Americans
just absolutely [__] all over Americans
hell man well
that's what they want the cruelty is a
feature I don't know if you noticed that
but the cruelty is a feature
of the Republican party at 100 is
it is
hando percento
it is the feature of it now I mean
you know there's a lot of there's a lot
of uh
politics that go into a lot of these
decisions right uh the one thing about
the uh
the wedding website maker apparently
these these [__] the the the couple
that they used in this decision and then
this case wasn't even real
of course it isn't and I don't know if
if you if you are aware of this
but again
we we should sue them anywhere and
everywhere we can take as many cases to
the Supreme Court and to the appeals
court as we possibly can [__] them
pile them up with them just do it just
do all of it [__] them [__] em [__] em
[__] them
and I know a lot of people are talking
because yesterday I hadn't asked me
anything on my patreon and someone asked
the question about packing the courts
now yeah well listen
pack the courts not pack the courts I
mean you know what whatever whatever the
hell you want to decide
but it doesn't make a hell of beans
worth a difference to yell and scream
and tweet pack the courts if you're not
gonna do something about it
yeah yeah that's right you're not gonna
I I understand I understand that you're
you're frustrated and you wanna you
wanna type it out on the internet you
want to say it right I get it right
that's why I'm [__] here every day
talking to you for two goddamn hours a
day
with the cathartic outrage and Amy
aiming aiming that strategic outrage
towards something that could make a
difference and I'm trying to tell you
what the politics are
so you can go out
and engage in those politics
it's a hundred percent what you should
be doing because folks if you've got
someone out there that is like well [__]
me I was counting on this student debt
relief look at them and say well then
here's what you can do to pay them back
for this never vote Republican ever in
your entire life and don't just don't
just not vote Republican tell those
[__] you're not going to vote
Republican because of this whatever this
is whatever this is
it might be the student debt relief it
might be the decision on affirmative
action it might be the decision based on
them legalizing hate towards gay people
in businesses
discrimination legalizing discrimination
against gays at businesses yes whatever
the [__] one is that you want to look
at them and say I'll never vote for
Republicans ever again for the rest of
my [__] life
this Roe v Wade whatever it is
whatever it takes for you tell them say
it out loud
in their face
with some with some outrage with some
passion tell them I am always going to
affiliate with Democrats even if I don't
like them
because you did this you [__]
scumbags
affiliation goes both ways folks that's
what I've been trying to tell you about
affiliation it's not it's not a [__]
fascist thing it's a human thing
it's a human reaction
we look for third party
confirmation
and we do it based on our affiliation
and it goes without saying that it's a
human [__] trait it's human again I'm
telling you we're not perfect we're not
inherently good
if you believe that we're inherently
good then why do you think we have such
scumbags in this country that have been
manipulated into being so [__] vile
huh and a lot of them would call me vile
like ah you [__] you're vile
you've cursed and you say crazy things
I am vile I am not the greatest person
ever hell I'm probably not in the
category of good
but at least I have some [__] empathy
you pieces of [__]
there's one trait one [__] trait you
can pick out of your miserable existence
to have that might be the one that'll
get you on the side of good
and they have none of it not a [__]
single shred of empathy
because they're selfish
it's time
that you get pissed
and it's time that you stay pissed
you tell those [__] wherever
you are whoever they are that you're
pissed they're gonna be pissed with you
they're gonna be pissed with you
this is not a situation where the
majority of the country believes this
[__]
that's a [__] lie that's the actual
big lie that's the big lie that they
keep telling you the big lie about
Donald Trump winning in 2020 is not the
big lie
the big lie is that the majority of this
country is just [__] deplorable like
the email lady said
[__]
most of the people that we consider
deplorables weren't deplorable until
someone gave them [__] permission
we must do the work
in real life we must do the work
again I know you feel like well Tony
alls I can do is tweet all I can do is
post on Facebook no that is not all you
can do you have a talent
every human has something that they're
very good at
whether it's texting making phone calls
sending emails I mean I'm really good at
talking I'm real I'm re I don't know if
you notice this
I don't know if you noticed I'm really
good at dying I'm really good at getting
busy I'm really good at cursing too I'm
[__] good at it there is not you're
not gonna find too many [__]
out there that are as good accusting as
I am it's just not gonna happen I
understand this that's why I do it
that's why I do it
yeah
this is what I'm good at
do what you're good at
I'm telling you they are not the
majority these hateful [__] bigots
are not the majority
they are not
they won't win if you stand up
they can't win if you engage in
democracy why you think they're so
scared of it
why do you think they're terrified of
democracy
they know they know it's their
ideologies demise
they know it
and again don't get stuck
on policy points don't get stuck on
fantasy
okay
a lot of people are gonna tell you oh
man we need to pack the courts
oh man we need to do this we need to do
that we need term limits
we need this we need that specifically
no what we need is for everyone in this
country to participate
to engage
doing their civic duty
knowing what the [__] is going on around
them and why it is going on around them
understand that this stuff isn't hard
yes it is a heavy lift
when you have fascist in your midst
and you have them meddling in our
democracy tearing it apart ripping it at
scene by scene by scene yeah it's going
to be a heavy lift and democracy is a
lot harder than autocracy than blindly
following one dumb [__] off the
cliff
but it's worth it
but it isn't that hard with political
rhetoric it isn't that hard to
politicize issues it isn't
don't be scared don't get scared of the
left elitist
when they tell you oh wait you can't say
that [__] you can't
say it
stop listening to the [__] snowflakes
stop listening to them
it's that time to be weak
now is the time to fight
and when you fight with your democracy
and you fight with your vote and your
ballot and your engagement you will win
you will win
it's not time to [__] turn your nose
up
oh
wow I just I just can't stand these
people who want this student debt relief
because I didn't get mine done shut the
[__] up
shut the [__] up if you're pissed off
because someone else is going to get
their student debt relief to make our
economy and our country better and you
didn't get it shut the [__] up I paid
mine off I'm a two-time College Dropout
and I had a shitload of [__] student
loans and no one came to save me do you
see me saying oh well [__] them [__]
them they they don't get saved because I
wasn't saved
when the [__] have we ever done that
stupid [__] in our country till now [__]
them and if you're saying that [__] [__]
you too if you're on the left and you're
saying wow they don't deserve it get
[__] get [__]
you don't have enough empathy to be on
the left you don't have enough empty
empathy to be in the pro-democracy
Coalition put your mug ahead on
[__]
that's right I'm calling you if you're
on the left and you're like well [__]
damn I don't want them to have student
debt relief anyways I didn't get mine
[__] you put your manga hat on
I'm calling you a trump supporter that's
right go vote for that [__] do
it
oh you can't stomach it oh well then
[__] grow up
and learn and learn what the [__] we do
in this country
learn what the [__] a quality equity and
empathy is about
learn that we don't [__] learn that
we don't oppress the rights of other
people and call it freedom
we don't discriminate against gay people
because you don't like them [__] you
oh oh you don't want to make gay wedding
websites don't make websites
don't make [__] websites Karen
don't make websites Karen
oh you don't want to cook gay wedding
cakes don't cook cakes Todd don't cook
cakes
bake them do you bake them do you cook
them [__] I don't know I'm pissed
oh I'm pissed
yesterday I tried to stay calm I tried
to stay calm with this the affirmative
action I really thought man we wake up
this morning I really thought maybe
these fascists would do the right thing
maybe they would come to their senses
I'm way too optimistic I guess
wow [__] me
it's time it's time we do something
about it though and I'm telling you
typing typing pact the courts into a
chat or into Twitter or into Facebook
isn't is a that that's not gonna help
it's not gonna do [__] okay that's not
gonna do [__]
it's just not
tweeting it's not gonna do [__] We're
Not Gonna tweet our way out of this
We're Not Gonna Facebook post our way
out of this no matter what meme you post
on Instagram it ain't gonna get us out
of it there's only one way to get us out
of this
and it's to engage in your democracy
it's to use your ballot
don't boo vote
yeah you can [__] boo all you want go
boohoo all you [__] want but if you
ain't gonna follow up with some goddamn
action and vote with your ballot you
ain't doing [__]
and if you ain't moving people's ballots
if you ain't trying to convince them of
what they're how important their ballot
is you ain't doing [__]
not a goddamn thing yeah and I'm I'm
shaking my finger
at the audience do it be mad at me be
prove me [__] wrong do it
I'm telling you
we can win this
we can win it
we can
we just can't get mired in these stupid
[__] arguments
with ourselves
it's time
now
laughs you didn't think I could go this
long on this did you
oh man
so how long do you think it's gonna be
until we see
a real a real
a real I'm telling you a real [__]
sign in a business
it says no gays allowed
what do you think couple days
huh but tomorrow it's afternoon maybe I
mean it's not gonna take long
nah it won't take long they're going to
take advantage of this [__] they're
going to take advantage of this
affirmative action result too there's
already people out there like oh man how
can we take advantage of this
what happened
you [__] doubt me I'm gonna show it
to you I'm sure when we come back next
Thursday I'm going to be able to pull up
something and say see here it is I told
you
I told you it wouldn't take long
and I hate to say that it's our fault
but when I say our
I mean all of us
we're all responsible for this
and I I know I know it only says one
person one vote I get it
and what's one vote right yeah what's
one vote
what's the big deal
you know it's not that important
goddamn right it's important look what's
happening
why do you think I'm so [__] pissed
off when people come at me when I'm
[__] when I'm like [__] tyt [__] them
[__] them [__] em
oh Tony you're you're going after Ty
they attacked the left no they don't no
they don't
they engage in self-suppression
they engage in self-defeetism which has
been the problem of the democratic party
this whole time
always
I'll boohoo Jill Biden's old get the
[__] over it
get the [__] over that [__]
come on man the [__] over it quit crying
quit being a goddamn snowflake get in
the fight
Joe Biden's gonna fight with you hey tyt
viewers who love student debt relief who
want free college hey tyt viewer who
loves that kind of [__]
Joe Biden's in the fight with you you
dumb [__]
he's in the fight with you
and he's the president
someone everyone's saying that I'm right
about tyt right that my opinion's
correct
I mean I get it right you're sick and
tired of hearing this self-defeatism
[__] right that's why you want cathartic
release like you get here you want
strategic outrage you want at least some
sort of [__] angry optimism right am
I am I right some pro-democracy
propaganda
as you might call it I don't give a [__]
call it whatever you want
whatever makes you feel good inside it
doesn't make me no difference
I'm not gonna get [__] when you call
it something that you want just just to
make it so fine whatever whatever floats
your [__] boat
but when tyt attacks Joe Biden because
of his age he didn't do this or he
didn't do that
he didn't do student debt good enough
guess what [__] he could have
done it the way you wanted and we'd have
the same result
understand he's fighting
understand he's there he's doing the
work
him and his administration he's not only
talking into a microphone he's got
plenty of people who know what the [__]
they're doing to try to get it done
and yeah there's a lot of fascists
forced working against him we get it I
think you get it as a tyt viewer I'm not
talking about Jared here Jared gets this
and I'm not saying tyt should not exist
don't [__] get it twisted I think tyt
serves a purpose but what they should do
is [__] not participate in
self-suppression
and self-defeatism Joe Biden's in the
fight with you you [__] idiots he's
an ally for what you want pretend like
that's the case
don't pretend like he's not because you
don't get your way
you're not gonna get your way hey you
average viewer just you I'm talking to
you I don't care who you are I'm talking
to you personally right now you're not
going to get everything you want
everything you want it's not going to
happen
it doesn't matter how great who you vote
for doesn't matter how great they are
when you vote for them you're not going
to get everything you want it is clear
that if you would have voted for Bernie
Sanders
in 2020 and Bernie Sanders would be the
president right now
you would not be getting student debt
relief
you got it are you got it
are you listening to what the [__] I'm
saying
you who wanted Bernie Sanders so he
could relieve you of all your student
debt would not have that
you understand that right it's not that
it's not because Bernie Sanders couldn't
have done what Joe Biden did or couldn't
have gone further than what Joe Biden
did it's that fascist stand in our way
do you understand the problem is not
that the problem is not that people
don't want these [__] things like
student debt relief like not
discriminating as [__] gay people
about a website or a cake for crying out
loud
to make sure that there's equity and
equality and diversity in universities
in this country especially the [__]
the big Institutes
that this country benefits from
diversity because it diversity is the
biggest benefit
the problem isn't that we're not
electing left enough politicians you
[__] idiots
it's that part of our country is deluded
and to keep voting for these [__]
fascists
that's the problem solve the problem
don't stand around bitching as a result
of the problem
solve the problem
if no Republicans would have stood in
the way of the student debt relief from
Biden we would already have it
it would have been done over with the
debt would have been relieved just like
Marjorie Taylor Green's PPP federal debt
by the way
Matt gatz PPP federal debt that's
already forgiven that's already done
no Republicans stood in the way of
Republicans and business people and the
rich the oligarchy the theocracy the
plutocracy in this country receiving
their relief no Republicans stood in the
way hmm I wonder what it could be I
wonder what the [__] it could be
so when you're mad at me for pointing
out that tyt is an absolute garbage can
that's a you problem not an us problem
you got it
I'm attacking the left like you say tyt
does tyt isn't attacking the left tyt is
helping the right
it's helping fascism you dummies
and until they [__] realize that and
change their tune they'll continue to
help fascism exist
they'll continue to help fascists get
elected you stupid [__]
so don't come in me
cause I'm right like Jared said I'm
right about tyt [__] I'm right
I'm correct trust me on this I'm correct
Nina Turner can kiss my ass
Jake and Anna can kiss my [__] ass
I don't give a [__]
and maybe maybe just maybe maybe just
maybe when we see that the problem the
problem here isn't the left
and the the moderate Democrats you're
not left enough
that the problem is the fascist the
Republicans who stand in the way of what
the people want maybe maybe just maybe
you'll get in that fight
and maybe when you get in that fight
with the rest of the pro-democracy
coalition
maybe the pro-democracy coalition
will take you [__] seriously I'm just
saying
so yeah Jared I I'm 100 correct thousand
percent correct
and if you don't like it [__] you kick
rocks you're not going to you're going
to keep listening to me
you're not going anywhere even if you
hate the [__] I say about tyt you're not
you're not you're not gonna go anywhere
and the reason why is because most the
people who came here from tyt and listen
to me [__] tell you the truth about
them you're like oh yeah that makes
sense
uh [__] you kick rocks I mean until you
[__] wake up
and realize that you're being duped just
like manga is being duped by the right
being grifted by the right from tyt yeah
fine whatever go go do your thing
yeah I mean you're gonna come back here
and be mad
you're gonna come back here and be man
but yeah that's cool
and some people are talking about some
personalities that are on them
that are on tyt oh they're good they're
great I'm not talking about every single
person who does content for
[__] tyt I'm talking about the people
who run it I'm talking to people who
promote it and the people they promote
like Nina Turner that [__] scumbag
that's right Nina Turner is an
anti-democracy scumbag
and you should not listen to her at all
matter of fact you should actively seek
her out and mock her at every turn she's
not good for democracy she's not she's
not in it for democracy she's not
she's a shill she helps the right
she helps the fascist
not Tina Turner no no not Tina Nina Nina
someone's asking Tina no not Tina Turner
Nina Turner
she's a she's a former Iowa state
senator which you know I've been
following Nina Turner for a long time
I've been listening to Nina Turner for a
long time I had high hopes
but she's a bonehead
and and she's not she didn't really
believe a lot of the stuff she says
she's using it as a grift to continue
her little her little spot as the queen
on tyt because they [__] love her
over there they [__] love her
anti-democracy [__] over there
[__] love it
yeah Tina Turner is is gone she's she's
deceased
this is Nina Turner with an Nina yeah
I'm a hillbilly what do you want from me
it may not
did I say Iowa I'm in Ohio sorry yeah
someone's pointing out Iowa Ohio what
the [__] you want from me I'm from
Missouri what are you gonna do what are
you gonna do and I'm pissed off and I'm
excited I'm excited that I get some
reprieve I'm glad I get some reprieve
and I'm so glad that you're going to be
out there in in and about our democracy
to be engaging in it when it is so
important to politicize these issues in
the correct way not in the tyt Nino way
the correct way that's what you want to
do you gotta do that
someone says yeah there is an a at the
end of Missouri
some people say Missouri
some people say Missouri some people say
misery
depending on how you're feeling in the
state
well here's what we're gonna do because
it's I'm hot and my ears are sweating
from these headphones it's a [__] hot
here my air conditioning is on full
blast and then it's still hot
[__] here thanks global warming
uh so I'm gonna take a quick break when
we come back I hope we have Gabe Sanchez
don't go anywhere don't don't touch that
dial we'll be right back right after
this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
oh
[__] I got the air conditioning on full
blast I'm still sweating my balls off
Lord It's Gonna help that I'm getting
pissed either
[Music]
eat it in hot not exactly helping but
you know I can't help myself I've got to
get pissed off it's just what I'm gonna
do have that strategic outrage yeah
looking for Gabe Sanchez here where is
he at where's he at where's he at uh
we're gonna do bone end of the week uh
here but I also want to get Gabe's
opinion on some of these things you're
gonna like the bonehead I think it was
pretty close this week on moon and I'm
not really sure
oh man someone says put a fan next to me
look
if I put a fan right next to me that's
all you're going to hear is in this
microphone is the fan
it's not gonna be good that's why I
can't have a fan on for two [__]
hours no listen yesterday after the show
I didn't ask me anything but I had to
take a quick break after show you know
you gotta go piss get something drink
get a snack and I had to cool down
that is warm my ass is sweating it may
not look like it it may look comfy over
here but it is
it's like a sauna now my my air
conditioning is on it just it just can't
keep up it's so goddamn hot
thank you global warming you know
electric bills High
trying to keep the lights on trying to
keep it going let's see here I'm trying
to get the bonehead of the week set up
here and when Gabe joins us I think he's
got I think he's got everything set up
here let's see I haven't heard from him
well I mean I did he said he'd be back
here in a bit he had a few things to
take care of here
so what other news is out there that you
want to talk about today huh other than
you know
these [__] boneheads no it doesn't
look like oh man wait what's this nope
that's not it that's not it oh man he's
way behind I can I can see that he's way
behind today yeah we'll get there we'll
get there what what other news you know
what I'm gonna see if I can show you
some clips here
um while we wait on Gabe Sanchez because
I think there was a few clips that I can
play
and we can talk about in the meantime
uh let's see let's see here
oh yes this one here this is great this
is great
oh someone's reminding me oh yeah by the
way
it's the last month our last day of
pride month right
and you can use the promo code Pride
at store not the Tony michaels.com a lot
of people have been posting their pride
merch
on Twitter and I've retweeted a few of
you so thank you for uh ordering Pride
March and thank you for posting some
pictures it looks beautiful it looks
beautiful the design game Sanchez come
up with is great
um Miss loveseek in the chat was the one
who suggested it first and then everyone
rang in with all their comments so we
Gabe decided that it was a great idea
and he went ahead and made this uh logo
the [__] logo with the pride colors
so if you use the promo code Pride if
you use it pride
and you get 15 off your entire purchase
at the merch store so just go to store
not the tonymichaels.com again that
store and yesterday oh my God there's a
lot of orders yesterday how many were
there Jesus [__] Christ
there was a lot of orders yesterday
so a lot of people are trying to get
their last minute pride month purchases
in and it's off everything in the store
so don't don't don't be you know whether
you want the [__] them stuff the pride
[__] them stuff you want to lock him up
like like lock him up this banners there
you get 15 off that Banner uh whether
you want some doubt me what what about
the let me Rake you have to let them eat
rake merch you got the you got the Surfs
Up [__] merch over there uh you
got you got Rhonda santis can go [__]
himself because he can't go [__] himself
Ron can definitely go [__] himself
speaking of that I got a clip for you to
show oh my God
this guy is gonna woke himself into not
being anything anywhere right oh my God
this guy just he can't stop saying the
word he can't stop saying the word it's
[__] weird let's listen to him
count how many times he says woke in
this clip let's count them let's see let
me turn this on here let me see if we
can get this going on here
let's see Florida we fought the woke all
across one and as president uh I will
fight the woke and the two situations I
will fight the woken rules I will fight
the woke and the halls of Congress we
will never ever surrender to the woke
Mob We are going to leave woke ideology
in the Dustbin of History Florida we
fought the so that's six times in 19
seconds that this dude said woke
laughs
oh [__] Hey Ron Hey Ron and anyone on
the Rhonda zantes campaign
can you get them on the phone can you
get the Rhonda Santos campaign on the
phone I want to talk to them why they
should stop saying the word woke stop
saying the word woke man
stop saying it
stop it's it's not gonna work
that no one likes that [__] even Maga
doesn't like that [__] that you're doing
where you say the word woke over and
over and over again
they don't like it it sounds really
stupid because you can't even Define
what woke is now this is this is crazy
because this is at the moms of Liberty
the uh the lady Nazis
you know you know what I'm saying man
but lady Nazis yeah the lady Nazis moms
of Liberty see here's the thing is when
you when you decide that you're gonna be
a fascist right you you use words to
Define yourself as the opposite of what
your goal is right because you can't you
can't you can't be like oh we want to
take away your rats that's what we want
to do
we want to oppress I mean you can't call
you can't call a group moms of
Oppression right
I mean I guess you can I guess you can't
some yeah some call it the clan Karen
Hood
but but when you when you when
when you're a fascist
and you decide to participate
in fascism and Institute it right you
Institute it in this little organization
where you burn books and you ban books
and you hate on the lgbtq community
because you hate them and you're trying
to solidify your hatred and you really
want to work on oppressing the rights of
other people you call yourself the
opposite of that because calling
yourself an oppressor is probably not
gonna sell that great in 2023 right well
really almost any time in history
just it's not a good sell right
that's why they call themselves the moms
for Liberty because they're not that
they're not for Liberty the [__] out of
here I mean if you think they're for
Liberty and they have this guy stand on
stage and say this Florida we fought the
woke all across the board and as
president uh I will fight the woke and
the corporations I will fight the woke
in the schools I will fight the woke and
the halls of Congress we will never ever
surrender to the woke Mob We are going
to leave woke ideology in the Dustbin of
History if that's if that's who you and
speak at your your little convention and
your name is Liberty you're not Liberty
you're not for Liberty you're not
promoting Liberty you're doing the
opposite and we know that's why you're
calling yourselves
the moms of Liberty
I like this one [__] for bigotry
ah Karen's for fascism God damn you are
the best audience
Clan Karen Hood is pretty good though
it's pretty good right
it's pretty good plan to Karen Hood now
boy oh and by the way by the way again
Rhonda santis can go [__] himself so if
you want to get 15 off uh your great
Florida merge here of Ron DeSantis can
go [__] himself go to store.d Tony
michaels.com use the promo code pride
and you can
tell Ron DeSantis to go [__] himself for
15 off why not why the [__] not might as
well you might as well
oh it's some [__] now okay let's see
what else do we get uh oh yes I want to
show you this so
um
a lot of folks are um wondering how this
came to be and how the right is
celebrating let me find it here
where the [__] I know I quote did he
delete
that [__] better not have the
lead of that son [__]
oh boy oh boy cause Matt I quote tweeted
Matt Walsh earlier
oh here it is yeah I didn't think that
hateful bigot would delete this thing
okay here you go you want this morning
they're trying to make this like they're
on mainstream media the right Wingers
they're on mainstream media this morning
talking about how this decision
um against the woman who claimed that
there was a gay couple who wanted a
wedding website she claimed that
apparently it's not true I guess that
there was no actual gay couple that
requested that you make this website but
you know whatever are we are we supposed
to expect that the right and these
bigots aren't gonna lie come on that
should be our expectation from these
[__] that's what it should be
um but in that decision this morning the
right wing is cheering it right they're
[__] cheering it on they love this
and here's because they they try to make
the case on mainstream media that it's
about freedom of speech but here's what
it's really about
Matt Walsh is gonna give it away here
really quick right and and this is this
is why I know that they're not going to
stop at this decision they're not going
to stop at this Supreme Court decision
they're going to try to Institute policy
all around the country wherever they can
to legalize hate and legalize
discrimination against the lgbtq
community I mean they've been trying it
for [__] years
and I've been telling you this is
they're not gonna stop they're not going
to stop their [__] snowball of
fascism they love this they love look it
ain't about freedom of speech Matt Walsh
says here he says the pride month has
been an absolute disaster for the lgbtq
cult which I don't know what that means
what does he mean the cult
what does he mean
oh he means the existence of people is a
cult I don't know I'm not sure oh I know
he's a [__] Nazi okay
um he goes on to say they've taken one L
after another I don't know what you're
talking about
one loss after I mean there's been a few
setbacks
but what what's the what yeah you guys
you guys pretending you boycotted Bud
Light and Target that's an l
for for the gay community what are you
talking about
Bud Light Bud Light had a float
in a bright parade with their [__]
name over they paid for the son of a
[__]
the CEO went on the news the other day
yeah he capitulated of both sides but
he's like look we've supported the gay
community for 25 years
[__] out of here we're gonna keep gay
people drink beer why don't you get what
don't you get you [__] little
fascists they drink beer
Okay so
here's here's where he gives away the
game
he doesn't say anything about freedom of
speech in this tweet notice and that's
because it's not about freedom of speech
it's not
it's about their right to discriminate
against other people they think the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is liberty and it's not
he says and now it ends them with losing
in the Supreme Court awesome stuff
that's Matt Walsh for you
because it's not about freedom of speech
it's about we don't want gay people to
exist
and the more anti-gay
an ant and probe Pro [__] oppression
laws we have against them the better it
is and here was my response to him if
you're wondering how the fascists are
viewing the skoda's decision it's not
about Free Speech it's about legalizing
hate that's what they want they want
their hatred to be legal and again I
tell you that's why they [__] love
Trump they [__] love Trump because he
allowed them to be the worst versions of
themselves
okay so let's see
um
it there oh here is the the president
United States this morning uh let's uh
let's show this here
let's show this here this is uh what
[Music]
um
the president has tweeted
again hey hey folks who want your
student debt relieved in any shape or
any form
whether you like Biden or don't like
Biden listen up he says Unthinkable and
he's talking about the Supreme Court
decision to strike down the Biden's
Administration student loan forgiveness
plan this morning and the Supreme Court
he says the president tweets this fight
isn't over I'll have more to announce
when I address the nation this afternoon
um does anyone know does anyone have a
a Time on when this is going to happen
let me see if I can look it let me see
if I can look it up here let's see what
we can find see if the president has it
scheduled so far and what time it is
ready to do you know a great place to go
look this stuff up if you want to look
it up uh C-SPAN c-span's boring as [__]
generally speaking like uh like their
production right but they they they
follow this [__] around let's see if
they've yet well let's see if they got
this presidential announcement on their
schedule because they'll carry it
that's the whole point of C-SPAN is to
show us this stuff you just gotta look
at it most Americans don't that's part
of the problem but that that's uh it
doesn't look like oh yes maybe at the
Daily Brief maybe he's going to come out
during the Daily Brief I don't know if
there's a special event scheduled for
this but if that's the case it's 2 15.
um
central time I believe is that right
or is it Eastern anyways it looks like
they're gonna do it
um possibly during the because I don't
see an announcement here
of when
they just said when let me go to the
White House's Twitter page see if we can
find this announcement I want to smoke
this out you know what I mean
I want to see when this is and that way
uh if anything else we might be able to
carry it live here
on the um
yeah and some people haven't found it
yet
uh that's uh no I don't see it on the
White House's page either so it doesn't
look like they've announced it yet but
he plans at least to make it a statement
and it might be during the Press
briefing
every day the the White House this White
House does a press briefing they
actually talk to the breast they let the
American people know that they can
answer questions about their policy the
administration
even if they're really stupid [__]
questions from the right wing they'll do
that so he might he might be he might
come out during the Press briefing and
give his statement there it's possible
um because I don't see an official date
or an announcement
um of him showing up and speaking kind
of like this guy showing up and speaking
um
I just got the best trains now I gotta
get this gay I always get this yes oh
yeah
oh happy June 30th to you James is and
and you as well and and what a what a
day for us to um decide to go on a five
day weekly
um you know everyone you know we gotta
take a break sometime you know what
after I have the same feeling whenever I
go on vacation there's always some big
story that drops oh my God [__] you know
you know what I thought yesterday at the
affirmative action I thought
I thought did you did you think I was
optimistic I was optimistic this morning
I was on the phone with someone I'm like
I don't know I think they're gonna
I and now that that the gay website
thing right the gay marriage website
thing well right yeah well I mean are
you do you expect it not to lie at this
point well of course well the guy also
the guy was like uh I uh I never
submitted that I don't know I never
requested that at all I don't know
what's going on
so tell the story tell the story well I
only know I only know brief information
which is basically like to summarize the
whole thing is like this case was
presented they argued on it and then it
turns out that the person that they
named in it never submitted this never
requested uh never requested what
their uh never requested their their
case to be seen right they never they
never put their name on it to be like oh
yeah I want to challenge this case
because I want it as a as a owner as a
creative of this I want to deny gay
people right but what did I say
yesterday you know I said it for women I
was like I was like this the passing of
of this decision in the Supreme Court
when it comes to affirmative action like
just like we said Roe v Wade it's going
to be one it's just one thing that
they're able to push forward you know
they're pushing the envelope they're
taking baby steps to say okay what else
can we strip away all right we're back
to [__] gay cakes now it's gay
websites right do you think do you think
lavish luxury vacations from people who
have signed copies of mineconf might
have something to do with this
look um yes
uh I mean I'm not saying there's a lot
of these people out in the world that
you will find that have a lot of money
that have signed copies and they're
proud of these signed copies of mineconf
right and you know and their names just
maybe Harlan Hitler that they have a lot
to do this but it seems like it seems
like that has something to do with it I
don't know you know it's like it's like
before when when uh when Clarence Thomas
was like oh I've never I've never seen
any cases that have come before me man
we talked about on the show it's like
there's no way
that this person did not have some some
connection
tangentially
indirectly directly whatever it might be
there is no way
that this billionaire who was the sugar
daddy for Clarence Thomas [__] taking
them all around and and [__] showing
them off to everyone else and say look I
got one of those black people it's like
I shot me I just got me a black friend
it's like chill it's chill man is that
is that like just the [__] richest of
the rich I've got a black friend well
that's the closest they can get back to
slavery look right look man not only do
I have a black friend I paid a lot of
money right I own this man I and I own
me a black friend and you can't believe
what this black friend what kind of
decisions he can make that is what they
I mean like look the idea God damn the
idea that
that there can be billionaires that can
influence
our highest court in the land right you
know it's never really been something I
would say that has been as exposed as
right now right because it was like oh
let me [__] just scratch this itch at
this scab and then it [__] comes off
and you're like oh this is actually a
[__]
uh infected wound man well and not only
that even even Alito has himself a sugar
daddy they all have some sort of person
that's [__] tugging them along you
know they've got their leash on and it's
got the [__] yeah because you can't
have one person buying them all right no
yeah yeah that's this thing Harlan
Hitler gets in the room with the Alaskan
Hitler right singer they get in a room
with some other guys and they're in the
room and they and they're talking about
how much money they got and jerking off
to [__] their their mind uh Ireland
Hitler's uh signed copy of Minecon
they're all jerking off to it circle
jerk you know Nazi circle jerk and
they're all standing there talking about
you know we control this [__] and here's
how we're gonna do it best I'm I'm gonna
buy me this one you buy you that one and
you buy you that one that way when we
all decide together what we want we just
come together and we tell and we decide
what we're gonna do and then we tell
them what to do individually and they
[__] do it and then no one no one's
not no one knows the difference because
I can't own all of them but we can own
them individual
I mean it's
it's not like Pokemon because you're not
trying to catch them all right exactly
many ways it's kind of like
it's kind of like a rich guy's team
effort right yeah it's it kind of
reminds me of well it recently changed
obviously before but I would say
Collegiate Sports and how it's a
monopoly right and how you can control
certain assets and what you can do what
you can't do obviously that changed
recently in terms of like name image
likeness but I will say the way in which
they Monopoly oh I mean you could
[__] OPEC whatever you want to call
it like it's a bunch of rich people or
or influential powerful areas people
can't countries Nations whatever that
are controlling interests to say well we
want to [__] inflate the price
artificially so we're going to restrict
the amount of Supply that's available so
we can make a new equilibrium
in the market and for these guys it's
like oh well they're all around a
[__] poker table being like okay what
are we gonna do this week so you're
gonna take Harlan you're gonna take
[__] Clarence out to your you know
Island right you're gonna take Alito out
to [__] fishing you're gonna do this
they're gonna do this they all you know
when when Republicans talk about a deep
State there is a deep State okay there
is a controlling body of people who are
uh
uh influential right powerful people
powerful white dudes billions of dollars
who can move people around tell them
what to do influence our politics our
laws and so forth and so when you look
at this situation this is the deepest of
States you can find you've got a group
of billionaires who have controlling
interests
in our Supreme Court in our Supreme
Court
then makes the the rules that you know
set precedent for the land
and a lot of those things are Fascist
right you've got a six to three decision
that happens most of the time uh you
know
three of those spots I would say were
stolen
uh uh but
that's that's what it is right it's
you've got you've got billionaires who
are just [__] you know they've got
their one player
and they move around and they and they
tell them what to do and like you do
this move you do that movie that's it
right well I mean that's the way it
feels that they're bought and paid for
yeah yeah
I mean I'm still wondering who paid
Brett Kavanaugh's dead off I mean
there's a lot of questions and I
wouldn't be surprised if it was a
billionaire why can't we ask these
questions what's wrong with asking these
questions these are just simple
questions
I can't say for certain that they're
someone that is paying off Brett
Kavanaugh's life but I can tell you for
a fact that there is
oh [__] well you know what let's just do
this we're at the bottom of the second
hour now we might as well can you can
you get confirmation for me because the
president tweeted that he's gonna say
something on the Supreme Court decisions
this afternoon but I'm not sure if he's
scheduling an event or if he's doing it
at the White House Daily Press briefing
um can you see if you can smoke that out
smell what I'm stamping in there oh wow
I'm smoking
so let's do this let's uh let's go to a
break when we come back we'll have uh
rather Gabe can figure out if Biden's
gonna do a special event or at the White
House briefing and
we're gonna do bone head of the week so
don't go anywhere bone of the week right
after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
wait was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of lamb jams skull
near run out Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the lived love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
here's Tammy
[Music]
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
no no announcement yet on the time
they must be still writing the speech
yeah it says it's from what I found it
says uh and enough it's from from the
White House in their uh their briefing
room announcement
um yeah what's that well that's what I
was ending the end of it says and later
today I will provide more detail on all
that my Administration has done to help
students and the next steps my
Administration will take yeah because
because they have a plan here I mean
yeah I'm sure
um it could happen during the normal
time which I think is like 3 15 Eastern
or something like it is it is 3 15
Eastern I believe is the uh when
um yeah because 215 Central is the White
House briefing so it's 3 15 Eastern so
that could happen then
um but here's the thing here's the thing
is that
um this this kind of confirms what and I
believe we talked about this when this
first came down the pipe like I still
have I still have the video on our
YouTube channel as the intro about Joe
Biden
um relieving student debt right yeah
that's the that's the that's the intro
or whatever
um let me see if I can pull that up
it's an old video a lot of people going
and comment like how'd that work out for
you I'm like well why didn't it work out
dummy like the reason why it didn't work
out is because Republicans are [__]
scumbags
like that that's why it didn't work out
yeah [__] idiots
I mean that that's the thing about the
student debt
um because there's gonna be a lot of
Americans that don't necessarily agree
with Biden are like Biden that are that
would benefit from this right because
there's people who have student debts
from all walks of life here in this
country that are going to benefit from
the federal government doing this I mean
it'd be one thing if Joe Biden's like
only socialist if he was like Rick Scott
he's like only socialists get the
student debt relief that's it no one
else no one else gets it only only a
self-proclaimed Biden loyalist gets
through student narrowly
no that's not what he's saying he's
saying look if you make under a certain
amount of money you have certain amount
of debt Federal government's gonna say
we're just gonna forgive that kind of
like the PPP loans and that's what I
want to know
all right because this morning I I want
I want my [__] money back
and I want it with high interest too to
be quite honest with you from Argentina
green Matt Getz yeah any any Republican
that received PPP loans that are
cheering this thing I want my [__]
money back because it's my money yeah I
mean I mean it's like your [__] JG
Wentworth commercial it's my money and I
want it now right right if if we can't
get students to get a couple thousand
dollars of their student debt relief I
want my millions of dollars back in the
PPP loans from and not only that
forgiven but this really goes back to
this Miss well misunderstanding but also
intentional misunderstanding that
Republicans pushed onto their
constituents and of course their
constituents don't like to fact check or
research or well and read and that's
what happens when you don't get an
education you don't go to college you
got someone like Marjorie Taylor green
or yeah well Marjorie Taylor green but
also you got someone like Lauren bobert
you know who says no we should abolished
a part of Education you know what also I
took the GED allegedly four times but I
didn't pass until somebody took it for
me again allegedly uh but what I do want
to call out is the fact that all of
these Republicans in that party said oh
no no no no if we forgive these loans
it's gonna it's gonna cause inflation
who's gonna pay this off you [__]
idiots
you [__] idiots I'm gonna say right
now you [__] idiots that is not how
it works okay
it's not like new Money's been printed
or old money's being used or this or
that that's not how that works
it's on a balance sheet okay and they
say bye-bye you're not you don't have to
pay for that [__] wait what do they say
bye-bye bye-bye we as we as taxpayers do
not have to cover that and not only that
but higher education holy [__] the rate
at which in uh tuition increases is
insane year over a year over inflation
you would think that the tuition cost
would say okay we're gonna go a direct
relationship over what inflation is
because that makes sense but higher
education like many of these corporate
companies who decided to price gouge
people during a pandemic or during the
last year to say oh well the cost of
goods have gone up so we're going to
raise the price you know inflation and
as inflation has gone down those
companies have said well
the new price seems pretty good for me
this is the same thing that's happening
here with with private institutions but
also again if it is removed from the
balance sheet of what you owe it does
not add a cost to understand it doesn't
cost us money we're not a payment we
don't have the money yet we don't have
the money yet okay so here's Kyle
Griffin's got a quote from President
Biden here on the student loan ruling
specifically
um and and the reason why I'm I'm
focusing on this one today is because
folks this is what is going to bring the
Coalition together now the decision on
affirmative action is going to draw a
lot of wedges between folks in this
country and uh but the but the two
decisions that were made today we can
politicize the [__] out of these just
like we did wrote the road decision and
I'm saying that out loud yeah it's
politics hey right Wingers you God damn
right it's politics [__] and we're
gonna make politics out of it you dumb
[__] that's what we're gonna do
we're gonna politicize the [__] out of
this every single moment whether you
like it or not that's what I'm gonna do
um but the two decisions today I think
are ones and and I know that is kind of
pathetic that those two decisions of the
affirmative action decision are the ones
that are going to be easier to
politicize but that's just the [__]
God's honest truth that you don't like
it well then you are coming here for the
wrong thing okay you're coming here for
the wrong thing
um but most Americans the popular
opinion in America is just leave
[__] alone let them marry who
they want to marry don't be [__]
discriminate against them because
they're the lgbtq community and oh by
the way what are you talking about I
don't want my student debt relieved the
[__] out of here with this nonsense okay
and and it's the Republicans who did
this no one else stood in the way of
this besides Republicans in particular
the former Republican Attorney General
Eric Schmidt who is now a United States
senator in Missouri this [__]
and he used Mohela if you're not aware
Mohela is a state agency that helps
collect the federal dollars
um for the federal government and oh by
the way you know mahila is funded by you
know how they make their money games the
federal government oh yeah no I know I
know them personally I had loans through
them I had to refill yeah yeah I thought
I didn't know if it was mojillo or
Mohela but well I mean I'm from Missouri
but I can tell you my experience with
that is I had loans with them uh when I
got out of school right they're like all
right six months after you get out of
school
let's start paying these things
meanwhile you're like I'm I'm still
[__] figuring out how to be an adult
here on my own I'm still trying to
figure out how to be an adult and this
is years years ago okay so right now or
or at the time I get out of school I've
got loans I gotta [__] set up a life
make these monthly payments of course I
can't make the maximum amount of payment
so I have to say well I can only
attribute this much money and they say
okay fine right well you still got to
pay these high you know these high
percentage these interest rates on them
and then I say at a certain point well
[__] man I gotta refinance this stuff I
gotta I gotta consolidate this into one
loan so then I go to somewhere and I re
I re I consolidate I say okay we got it
down to one I got it down to a fixed
interest rate and then that company was
like guess what after about six months
they sold it back to mojila and was like
they're like yeah oh yeah you can go now
you can pay us with this new
consolidated loan that we originally
gave or got from this uh third party and
we took it back so then it went [__]
full circle and I had to pay all them
you know it was it it's crazy the way in
which this [__] shell game of who you
gotta pay when and how much you got to
pay and which one you can defer and how
long you can defer and this and that and
it's like it also goes back to this idea
that even yesterday where the Supreme
Court decides on uh on removing
affirmative action right and where and
everyone's like oh affirmative action we
should remove that because you know it
it shows that it's actually you know uh
uh Reverse Racism because we have to
make sure that we get people who aren't
white in our school
it goes all the way back I mean there
was a there was a breakdown I saw last
night that was very concise within 60
seconds and it was basically said like
if we
don't allow this right where they
basically all stems back to redlining
right you've got redlining redistricting
those places don't get researched they
don't get funding which means they don't
get the same type of resources or access
that someone in a wealthier neighborhood
would get right such as preparing for
tests or exams standardized tests s-a-t
a-c-t and those are the same tests which
by the way do not tell you someone's
intelligence they just tell you how well
you can prepare for an exam and how and
what the strategy is and those tests are
used to admit those people in those
schools and without having affirmative
action you have to rely solely on groups
that are wealthier and more resourceful
and more prepared versus groups that
don't have those things right and if you
break it all the way down it really is
like it is to combat racism so the idea
that people were like oh well this is
Reverse Racism no it's to fix a problem
that you you
that that is put in place that you are
unwilling to accept the truth about
right and they're like oh well this is
going to take away from my slide look
man you had an advantage your whole
[__] life shut the [__] up okay well
listen until until we come to grips with
legacy admissions where people are
admitted to places like Harvard because
Daddy and their granddaddy went there
the [__] out of here with this people
are going to Harvard because they're not
uh they're not they're not qualified
they're just there because of their skin
color you're just there because of your
skin color you [__] idiot or you're
just dead or yeah Chad or you're just
there because you know one family member
decided to make a very significant
donation to a library whether your
name's on it or not and that was a very
very influential move that got you past
the admissions process and let's also
accept the fact that it is very
difficult to get into Ivy League schools
but it is not that difficult to stay in
it now I've watched some clips uh and I
don't know if it's Harvard I believe it
was Harvard it was an Ivy League school
and it was an auditorium full of
students there were students that were
going to school and they were having a
big discussion and debate
um that there was the the professor the
the leader of the debate the moderator
of the debate on stage and he was asking
questions to the students they passed
around the microphone and it was funny
because they were kind of having this
debate of affirmative action right and
affirmative action in in in Elite
schools especially in this country
um which again I don't know how Elite
Harvard is Ted Cruz went to [__]
Harvard so I mean it can't be that
[__] Elite I'm I hate this asparagus
Barack Obama
there are a significant amount of people
that have come out of the Ivy League
schools that think they are [__] uh
better than other people right because
they have that right they went to
Princeton or Yale or Dartmouth or brown
or whatever it might be well the
majority of these Republicans went to
these [__] Elite schools and then
they're trying to Gaslight us that oh
the Democrats or the elitist look
[__] if you think I'm an elitist
I'm listen I'm a two-time College
Dropout I know I have a problem saying
it because it's the [__] truth and I
did it because of reasons
of that I had a small family I couldn't
[__] afford it I didn't want the
[__] loans to saddle me for the rest
of my life I saw where it was going and
I told them to go [__] themselves and
what I did was I did what most Americans
do we don't have a college education
[__] work my ass off to try to make a
living barely sometimes and sometimes I
did all right but that's that's the
[__] point is I don't want to listen
to Ted Cruz who went to Harvard to tell
me that I'm a [__] Elite because I
because I believe in Liberty get the
[__] out of here with that nonsense you
can go [__] yourself you can go to
Mexico and you can [__] stay there
Cancun Cruise you piece of trash Harvard
trash but here's the thing if this is
the case that that we're supposed to
expect
that elitist and and people come out of
Harvard that are smart and warriors
ticker's a [__] lawyer it can't be
that hard to get into Harvard and it
can't be that hard to be a [__]
lawyer it can't it cannot be it can't be
that hard it should be I think it should
be I think it should be a lot [__]
harder to get into Harvard and a lot
harder to be a [__] lawyer maybe we
wouldn't have [__] boneheads like
that are running around talking about
how Donald Trump you classified
documents with his mind and [__] like
that did you know Casper tells a [__]
lawyer too did you know that
is a lawyer Christina Bob's a [__]
lawyer Tom Benton wants to be a lawyer
he's not a lawyer but they're as dumb as
he is no damn you're right okay yep yeah
he's a [__] lawyer Cash Cash shop
pramod cash is an American attorney yeah
yeah it is not that hard and I'd hate to
disparage any attorneys out there but
listen if you're standing on your
soapbox going look I'm an attorney
you're that doesn't mean [__] to me
right it doesn't mean [__] to me
at all and it shouldn't mean [__] to any
of us really at this point you're just
[__] talking out your ass I mean [__]
I talk out my ass two hours a day I
ain't got a law degree and I consider
that a badge of honor and I consider
that I'm a two-time college at Dropout
as a [__] badge honor you know why I
considered that a badge of honor because
here's why because I didn't buy into the
[__] that I meet the individual me
Tony had to have a college degree to be
something successful I didn't buy into
that argument you know what makes me you
know what makes me ahead of everyone
else in this country you know what makes
me ahead of everyone else I'm a man
and I'm white
did you know that that that that's my
privilege yeah that's why I can be a
two-time College Dropout and still be
successful in that in that about a
[__] I'm 200 years ahead of you
some [__] because I'm a man and I'm
white and I get I can be a [__]
deadbeat College Dropout who it doesn't
matter the reason why I dropped out and
I can [__] be successful and all that
[__] and all that and it doesn't matter
because there is such thing as white
privilege there is I'm [__] 200 head
years ahead of you now that's not my
fault that's not my problem but it is my
problem if I promote it is it is my
problem if I don't have empathy for
people and understand that that's the
[__] truth and it's also my problem
if I don't use that privilege to [__]
smash it into Oblivion because that
should not be the case it shouldn't be
that someone is born 200 years ahead of
someone because of privilege and then go
there's no such thing as white privilege
and oh by the way we're going to take
advantage of our white privilege and
we're going to make sure that we're
gonna make sure that only white people
get into the elitist universities that
way it's only whites that look Elite
yeah because we don't like when Barack
Obama says he's from Harvard we [__]
hate that and that's why Ted Cruz
[__] doesn't he he doesn't like to
say he's from Harvard because he doesn't
want to appear to be one of the I well
yes they don't they they love to bash
the coastal Elite they want to be
oppressed they want to be oppressed
out here East Coast ivy league Elite
schools right and again that's why I I'm
telling you out loud and some people
aren't going to [__] like it that I'm
saying yes I'm privileged yes I took
advantage of it because I'm a white man
but that's what that's the system in our
country that's what happens right that's
the thing that's and that's why Ted Cruz
is running away from his [__] Harvard
degree because he doesn't want to look
like an elitist because he wants you to
think that he's oppressed he wants you
to believe that and just because someone
gets into an institution gets a degree
and goes to Harvard and wears the
sweater that says Harvard across it you
know what I know people personally this
is [__] hilarious who wants a sweater
they
and they post they wear that [__] for
their Instagram post
okay who would know any different dude
you're not going on foreign
Harvard does these um
these like uh um they're like classes
right they're not it's not a degree it's
not like um it's it's not part of
Harvard they do like the extension yeah
they do well no but it's not part of the
accredited school it's it's like it's
like a convention it's like um uh let's
let's say you want to go get a
designation in the insurance industry
right yeah yeah and oh and like a
certification right you can go get a
certification at Harvard yeah at Harvard
that way you can put on your resume that
you got this certification at
I personally know this uh he's douchier
than [__] you can only imagine who he
votes for huh I wonder and he wears he
wears a [__] Harvard sweatshirt
because he runs like uh like 5Ks and
[__] he's always wearing his Harvard
shirt his Harvard sweatshirt
like he went to Harvard and [__] like
you gaslighting [__] yeah you
can I bet you can guess you who he vote
who he votes for and who he supports who
do you think I don't know if I had to
guess it'd be I don't know the
Republican Party well not there you go
there you go not Republicans in general
okay okay it's only one it's only one
you know make America great again
Harvard
I mean and I'm sure if you talk to him
he'd be like oh the Democrats are all
lead to some liberals they're already
just like dude you gotta you got a
Harvard shirt on you're bragging about
going to Harvard when you can go to
Harvard that's real [__] and I'm no more
than one of these [__] I'm no
more than one person in my life that
were just total [__] douches yeah
that would support Maga you know this
idea and they love Trump and they're
like oh he's not a fraud he's not a con
man like you're following in his
footsteps wearing your [__] Harvard
sweater like come on man did you go to
Harvard well yeah I gotta I paid listen
I paid 500 for three-day certification
in dumb [__] okay and I got it from
Harvard I'm like okay yeah okay all
right you should you should ask them no
next time be like Oh How would how are
the four years at Harvard and that I
mean like what is it like sixty thousand
dollars per year now so you're talking
is it only that much I figured Harvard
was more well I think it might be more
when
what's Law School
uh but what but what I was gonna say but
that's I don't know if that's I don't
think that's including
um room board all that [__] it's just a
tuition yeah yeah
uh 57 000. yeah
someone's getting on to us in the
background for not getting to the back I
know I know okay do you have time do you
have seventy three thousand six hundred
dollars
per year yeah do you have time today are
you are you like are you having I mean I
can go but I don't want to go too long
so so we got an extra hour no we don't
have an extra hour man I'm just playing
with this [__] let's get what this [__]
this is the last time dog this is the
last this is the last day for our five
five days now I want to point this out
real quick because I I've had this in
the background so let me let me uh point
out this uh president bite then we'll
move on to uh what we normally do on
Fridays what is it called bonehead of
the what what is it but bone bone out of
the week that's right everyone's asking
us to get the bonehead okay so President
says on student loan ruling he says the
hypocrisy of Republican elected
officials is stunning they had no
problem with billions in pandemic
relieve loans to businesses including
hundreds of thousands and some cases
millions of dollars for their own
businesses like literal elected
officials in their own businesses and
those loans were forgiven forgiven by
the administration but when it came to
providing relief to millions of
hard-working Americans they did
everything in their power to stop it and
that is the [__] thing here folks if
you're mad about this direct your energy
to one [__] Republicans one it
is their fault they are the ones who
stood in the way if they would have said
you know what that's a good idea for the
economy we're not going to say a goddamn
word it had already been done just like
these PPP loans they didn't say [__]
there ain't one attorney general in the
Republican party that brought a lawsuit
to make sure the Republican elected
officials who own businesses didn't get
their [__] PPP loans
that's all you gotta [__] know and
the last thing I'll say on that is the
fact that they were the people who got
those loans right these Republican
lawmakers these Representatives you know
these senators
they all had the heads up man they all
knew they had the [__] skinny on this
[__] they knew what was going to happen
they knew what the they knew what the
protocol was what the application
process was they knew exactly how to
file it where to file it when to file it
seems convenient it seems like they were
given the [__] answers to the test
before it's almost like they were making
the answers to the test oh like they
were making the questions the answers
and they were grading the papers it's
almost like they did I can tell you for
a fact that myself as well as two other
people that I know that have small
businesses and I was looking to get a
loan for my uh consultancy this to
design a work during that time
and I know two other people who also try
to and get the minimum ten thousand
dollars right and they couldn't even get
approved and they had applied the you
know the that the next day or whenever
the whenever the portal opened to like
start this process
and they were denied they went to the
bank and they're like what's going on
they're like oh well you know a lot of
people took out these money and they got
in here before you and they're like how
is that possible and they're like well
they
they just happened again in early which
shouldn't be possible right there
shouldn't be you shouldn't have an
advantage
over other people
because you know this you know it I
would equate the PPP loan situation to
insider trading they had information
that benefited them financially and they
acted on it either directly or
indirectly while other people were left
to wait for public information
and I don't think it's very fair
and to me well I mean I'm just saying if
they're looking if it sounds like
insider trading man if you're looking
for fair and unrigged don't go to the
Republican Party Debbie here um before
we get bone Head Start It says that's a
long vacation too long I don't know if
you can have too long a vacation that's
like too much money or too much fun you
should hear that song it's like too much
money what's that mean you know you
never heard anything yeah you're not in
the country music it is a long vacation
it's well uh earned by Gabe
um he needs he needs a long vacation you
can blame it on him that's yeah he's the
one who made that call it definitely was
no I'm joking I'm joking full
transparency I'm the one who said we're
not gonna We're not gonna do shows
Monday Tuesday Wednesday I want to give
everyone a good break and the ability to
go out there and yell and scream at
these events at their friends their
family all the people watching fireworks
yeah
well if you drink your queer beer
remember yeah it's true yeah it really
piss him off bring bring cases of Bud
Light and make it free just have a big
cooler and then and put a sign on it at
the fireworks thing free queer beer
Turn Turn You Gay
I turn to gay I turned I turned gay with
the queer bear
also I also I want to say it is a
vacation too for the moderators the
moderators uh totally deserve and earn
this vacation they work so hard in the
chat and we love them
there are other people behind the scenes
that help us right there's other people
that that that do the work and they need
their queer beer too that's right that's
right so I I know it's I know it's long
I know it seems too long but we'll be
back on Thursday what do you think about
it right we leave
and we come back for the start of
bonehead of the week that's right so
it's almost like it's almost like you
you when you like when you were a kid
and you were like taking a long trip in
the car yeah and your parents like just
go to sleep and when you wake up you'll
be there yeah yeah it's cool no problem
so just close your eyes after bone end
of the week and wake up and then you'll
be voting for the next bone of the week
no big deal no big deal so Debbie I I I
apologize but we we do need we do need a
little bit of a break because we
probably won't take another break until
Thanksgiving really maybe a few here and
there but yeah yeah not a not a big
holiday break until then so let's do it
let's do bonehead of the week
foreign
[Applause]
but I do the strawberry frozen ones with
sugar instead of salt that's right [__]
you if you don't like it hey wait hey
what lasts for me
what's wrong with that oh my God what's
wrong with it
sugar yeah what the [__] are you doing
oh you already have this you already
have sweetness inside the margarita I
don't want to argue too much with you
because we're trying five margaritas
with a with a sugar rim that's too sweet
for me bro you know what you know what's
crazy is when I ordered it because we
were at a Mexican restaurant and um they
were like small medium or jumbo and I'm
like medium and then someone else
ordered a sangria at the table and they
were like large and then they came and
my medium was the same as their large
I'm like what the [__] wait a second
it's like the whole it's like the whole
Starbucks thing you know what I mean
because is it is it medium is it large
or is it jumbo you know what I mean
Grande right denti I don't know I don't
go to Starbucks so I don't drink I have
no idea the [__] Paul red yeah
venti is 20. that's 20 ounces
congratulations you're stupid in three
different languages
I was like I was like I'll take the
medium it's like the middle one right so
there's the small one there's the medium
one and then there's the the jumbo the
big one yeah but they ordered a large
and they got the same one I got I was
confused maybe maybe the guy was like
this guy needs a large margarita I I did
not need the jumbo by the way okay
because but you didn't say no to it well
no no see here's the thing is like if I
start with tequila oh [__] because I I'm
gonna drink Jaeger later that's what I'm
gonna do but if I start with tequila I
get real happy right tequila is like a
happy liquor right makes you happy makes
you horny sometimes people right I mean
like I'm saying like for some people it
makes them happy why do people you know
they can get aggressive well right but
later on that's right that's that's too
many but you got one two you know good
sized five Margaritas one Margarita two
Margarita you might want butt stuff by
the time you get to five I'm just saying
okay but here's the thing knock it
tequila to
yeah tequila is the happy horny
um and it's there's other ones out there
that can make you happy and horny but
tequila is one of them okay can we get
to business here with the uh that's good
all right speaking of
I don't know what was I speaking of
bonehead of the week Donald Trump
Marjorie Taylor Green Tommy tuberville
did you know Tommy tuber real thought
there was only two branches of
government he can only name two branches
did you know that Tommy tuberville yeah
I don't know it's a piece of [__] I mean
I was just a good one I was gonna say
he's a [__] idiot should we start
with Tommy what did Tommy do or what
didn't he do uh would be the keyword
Tommy Tommy tuberville you know decided
to call out and say oh man I can't wait
for this money to come into my state and
we're going to have this celebration oh
is this the dunk is this why you ended
up is this the dunk that Joe Biden did
on yeah and this was just one of several
dunks and I mean dark Brandon came back
I mean especially today right like he's
doing a he's doing a [__] round of
financial dunking to be like you voted
against this bill you didn't want your
constituents to have access to the
government funding you didn't want your
area to be improved by government
assistance and and infrastructure
someone who makes gifts do not make this
gift it just it just came in my mind
even though the Oprah you get a car you
get a car you get a car don't do this do
not do this the Oprah GIF where she
would say you voted against it and then
put a republican you voted against it
and put a republican you vote against it
but a republican you vote against it put
a republican all the ones that are like
oh yeah it's great because even even the
governor of Missouri the governor the
governor Missouri is like oh this is the
greatest thing ever we're so happy that
rule Broadband is here like your entire
party including you spoke against it
yeah what are you talking about I mean
Tony look look all I'm saying is if you
vote against it you put your foot down
to say how do I keep my constituents
dumb so they don't have access to
challenge and question the very thing
that I spread in my speeches right and
now they're like oh [__] man it's about
time we got online we've been offline
for the last 50 years you know it's like
a lot of these places don't have basic
what I would what I would consider I I
believe that internet is utility right
now it should be should be considered it
is and that it should be
obviously uh private companies think
differently and you know what at one
time I want to bring this up you know
one time electricity was not considered
a public utility
thing yeah I mean if it was up to the
Supreme Court I'm sure they would
[__] take it all the way back they'd
be like electricity [__] that [__] we
don't need it they're like you don't
need anything yeah that's you don't need
agencies to regulate you know people to
make sure it's safe you don't need
anything get those babies hands in those
cogs Jesus that electric it's woke the
electricity stiff I'm just saying I'm
just saying but the reason that Tommy
tuberel is on bonehead of the week
this week is because he decided to take
credit and be super jubilated about
getting money and he was one of he was
one of the first ones out there
this is socialism we can have this this
is how we're gonna convert into a
Venezuela right socialist
M and here's dark Brandon absolutely
Duncan tuberville in the trash let's
listen that's what the bipartisan
infrastructure law does
well before our kids and grandkids only
bigger
just last week we announced our plan to
bring affordable high-speed internet to
end the decade of that unaffordable and
and accessible internet to every home in
America every small business in America
and so no one's surprise
there's no one's surprise
let's bring along some converts
people strenuously approach voting
against it when we've had this going on
socialism this was going to bankrupt
America
well there's a guy named tuberville from
Alabama from Alabama who announced a
strongly opposed legislation now he's
hailing his passage here's what he said
quote it's great to see Alabama receive
critical funds to boost ongoing
Broadband efforts
too bad he didn't have [__] to do with
it this is like this is like uh DeSantis
being like hey everybody check out this
big check and everyone's like oh this is
great meanwhile people who just do a
basic Google search go that [__]
said no to this [__] all right right one
of the people that didn't want he called
it socialism and said it's going to
destroy our country now it's like I want
to destroy our country with all this
money that I want to take credit for
I wonder if any social programs I wonder
if they really believe that it would
destroy our country hmm
[Music]
I mean let me correct myself most of
them know
that this money is necessary and it does
help their areas
however there are some people who are
[__] idiots and they really do think
that taking money in this way as if we
haven't done it for years before this
and existed with no problem right
now those people definitely I think
there there is there's definitely a
handful of people that are sitting
lawmakers okay one of which is probably
Lauren bobert who can't spell the word
impeach okay
who wants to impeach Joe Biden or you
know in 2021 she wanted to meet Joe
Biden because she couldn't spell that
word
uh but you you we probably do have a
handful or so or more uh sitting
Republican representatives and Senators
who actually believe that this money is
a slippery slope it's like a gateway
drug to socialism they're like once you
take once you take one dollar once you
take a big big old dab of that of that
Broadband baby once you get broadband
and you're paying 99 a month because
that's the thing it's not like the
government's giving you Broadband yeah
they're just laying the line so someone
can bring you the service so you can pay
them a private company for the service
you dumb [__] they literally
literally this is socialism it's
socialism for the private companies you
stupid bastards it's not it's not
socialism for the people they're just
now gonna get access to broadband
because the government made sure to give
the [__] private company the money to
light a [__] lines so they can get
Jesus Christ it's almost like it's
almost like uh socialism feeds
capitalism oh my God it's almost like
the government it's almost like the
government the government is a customer
it's a [__] crazy Jesus Christ you
know who doesn't understand any of this
he's speaking of dumb ass [__]
bone-headed lawmakers
one of our other person persons if you
want to consider a human if you would
put her in that category representative
Marjorie foot Petty Yeti three-toed
Taylor green is she still using the name
Taylor is her main name Taylor or green
which one is it I think her middle name
Taylor no no her no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no Taylor is not her
middle name but one of us in their main
name one of his married name
I think maybe I'm wrong I don't know I'm
wrong I mean three names she's got her
three toads like I always thought that
it was she got three names she took the
green right she did take that she took
she took Green from Perry green right
um
okay but I make her last name her maiden
name is Taylor I think it is so what did
she do I mean what didn't she do you
asked me this last night and I said just
existing out of the week she was [__]
breathing because I was trying to figure
out because he sent me a list of like
five or six names I'm like okay yeah
cause I figured she would win she man
she used to be uh she win for a win well
there's a few things so uh she compared
Ukraine's forces to Nazi army which is a
big right-wing talking point right but
there was a um
there was a link I sent you yesterday
yeah there was something there was
something um yeah yeah so we hadn't
talked about we didn't get time this
week talked about I'm like okay Alice
put her on the bonus so we can talk
about that uh oh
um
which one was it because it's fine there
was a spine oh yes where she got real
she didn't realize
so this is the first one not this isn't
that one but this is another one about
Marjorie Taylor green this is one of
those uh Jeopardy things where you're
like I'll take 500 uh for things that
didn't happen
like I honestly
Marjorie Taylor green and then I'm still
working on this one oh this is this is
the picture this is this is the picture
that she promoted her podcast with right
right so this is a real thing that's
just the first one this is the other one
I want to say that this looks like all
AI this doesn't even look like
this doesn't even look like um it's
it's horrible so she literally she is
bringing a a
what is is that what kind of gun is it
some kind of machine gun to the castle
[__] uh what the [__] is this
I get it she's trying to look cool right
yeah she's trying to look cool but but
this looks like it's it's it's a gun
like it looks like it's got one of those
round like [__] huge like it's like
one of those ones that you would shoot
off and there's like a [__] like it
looks right I don't know let me try to
find something that's like this it looks
like yeah it looks like something
determinate and then she's in a Hummer
here it looks yeah yeah but again you
know it's like some some like this right
like this size and it's a [__]
explosive explosive kind of capsule what
the is this her logo for her her podcast
yeah man yeah that's it yeah I thought
it was I thought it was something
different
this is a different podcast why why is
she doing a different one is she doing
two of them from what I understand
unless she rebranded she's still got MTG
MTG live and then she's got MTG
Battleground okay and this is the one
where she's had on her boyfriend so wait
so wait a second wait a second wait a
second you're saying that people in
Georgia are voting for a person who
has two shows and and and then is trying
to be a congress person is that what
you're telling me it's quite possible
because that's [__] wild [__] in it
you know I mean like when you when you
elect
like I'm gonna go to Congress for you to
represent you you're like well I know
you got six shows that you're doing and
not only do you your own six shows
you're like doing like six yeah
you're no longer on Steve bannon's show
but you were on there for a while right
right Fox News like you're doing and
really it's not anything but to to
Peddle your own [__] stupid social
media pages and it's like actually I
think this is hold on hold on hold on
hold on I think I don't think this is
actually her
[Applause]
look at her face
because I'm looking at it right now
I'm telling you this is a this is this
is either she's been [__]
photoshopped to like clean her face up
of all her Hagrid [__] demonic forces
but I also
oh my shit's all [__] jacked
oh God damn let's see if I can see if I
can zoom in on no it's why the [__]
ain't it let me what the [__] is going
on
that's not what I want either son of a
[__]
I'm gonna find this stock image I'm
gonna I swear to God I'm gonna find it
oh [__] I might even find it on the show
right now but I'm gonna find it and I'm
gonna [__] do a whole thing on this
yeah okay well you got me all [__] up
here ah [__]
I'm trying to zoom in and I [__] my
whole system up here God damn it God
damn it okay let's you know let's take
that there we go okay now and now I'm in
a better shape all right all right oh
boy you're trying to get all right okay
so here I'm gonna if you wanna
um here's the here's the best I can do
on zooming in for now because I I'm just
messing my screen okay well anyway the
the point I'm trying to make is if you
were to look at her face it doesn't
really look like her face it looks like
it's been cleaned up and or it's a
they've used artificial does it say that
it's examination and they've used
artificial insemination to uh to develop
this uh
um oh my God I'm gonna find this
artificial inseminations
that's right I invented the joke you
don't get to steal it
out there okay so that's one reason why
Marjorie Taylor green was on the bone of
the week I want to do this this spy
thing yeah I'm trying to find it send me
that [__] and she tweeted it right
she was like oh here she here wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait there we go yeah there we go
it looks like she's taking a [__]
I mean dude if you like it think of this
it
like to take the gun and the the Hummer
out of it right yeah if you like if you
knew she was in the bathroom taking a
[__] and you [__] kicked open the
door and she'd look at you this is the
look that you'd get like whoa hey man
I'm taking a [__] that's that's the look
that is indeed the look of like well
maybe it's
[Music]
this is really weird I'm telling you
dude it's either somebody had to
photoshop and put your face up will you
email or press offers and ask if they
it's that one cuck who always goes and
uh he's always there with the glasses
and he's always like I'll get out of the
way get out of the way stop harassing
her well I know but I want you to email
their office and ask is this an actual
picture that you guys have photoshopped
like this because it looks that's real
or is this artificial insemination yeah
is this artificial is it uh is it real
or is it fake because I think it's
[__]
did you find the Tweet where she's like
ah they're spying on me they're changing
my TV sorry sorry sorry sorry because I
wanna because we didn't get the poke fun
at this uh this year so I want to poke
fun let me find it let me find it I want
to poke fun at that one
um and that's when you said last night
that that was one of the reasons why you
wonder on bony I'm like yes let's do
that one I want to [__] mocker for
that it's so here's here's the gist of
it she's claiming that someone hacked
into her TV is that what is that I mean
she believes and that's someone all
right would be interested enough in her
to Spiner now maybe that's for you know
like I'm not saying that this is like an
explosive kind of story but there might
be something to really like
you know she you know my she might want
to pipe down on the bombs thing on the
things that she's talking about because
you know if he doesn't
then she's going to uh be busted
okay
oh
Marge you are a [__] idiot here she
is
um when is this let's see what was this
dated the 25th June 3rd June 25th June
25th okay so she says last night in my
DC residence
that's a weird way to put it the the
television turned on by itself
and the screen showed someone's laptop
trying to connect to my TV
Okay so
I don't know what that has to do with
the rest of this when I read this I was
like what why is this two tweets that
you accidentally tweeted as one just for
the record I am very happy I'm also very
healthy and he willing exercise
what does that have to do with someone
hacking into your [__] by the way yeah
like I don't understand it like what
what I think she's trying to be like I'm
not crazy guys okay like sure I talked
about the [__] Satan and the Deep
state in the cable and this and that but
I'm like oh my god dude I really she's
like please guys no 5150 here okay I
don't want to be this is off tied up I
don't want to have a straight jacket I'm
not crazy this gives off the mam urine
Wendy's yeah Vibe ma'am this is the
Wendy's
this is a why are you saying this stuff
this is weird this is like somebody
being like I didn't [__] my pants I'm
like why would you say that why would
that was random why would you talk about
[__] in your pants and like I didn't
you're talking about [__] in your pants
I'm not talking about [__] my pants like
you just brought it up
this is weird nor do I have anything to
hide listen I tweet a lot of crazy [__]
I'm gonna admit it and I entered some
[__] after I tweeted I'm like I probably
shouldn't have tweeted that
but I'm not gonna delete it right but I
have never deleted I don't have anything
to hide I don't know it just gives off
this stints that you probably have um a
lot of [__] to hide I'm just saying I'm
just saying it's weird it's a it's a
little it's a little weird you know it's
a little weird
she says I just love my country and the
people and know how much I've been
screwed over by the corrupt people in
our government and I'm not willing to be
quiet about it or willing to go along
with it what what
the people in my head are telling me
that that they don't like me and I have
to deal with that it's like is she is
she okay so it feels like
she's trying to make a coherent thought
here but she's very unsuccessful and I
think what she's trying to say and what
she should have just did was in all caps
put the Deep state is after me because
I'm the pipe bomber possibly maybe uh
maybe not really I have nothing to hide
no one's asking questions why aren't we
talking about the pipe bomber
ah this [__] trunk man I still wanted
to make fun of this tweet I'm so glad we
put her on bone near the week so we can
make fun of that tweet
she always she always provides a good
time because every week you're like hey
man that was some crazy [__] she did
last week and then Monday she's like
oh my God wait wait it gets way better
oh my God you can't you can't make this
[__] up
okay so I gotta go back a second all
right this is this is [__] wild I
just because I went to put down the this
tweet sucks yeah because when whenever
we show someone's tweet like marjor
Taylor green I always put in the reply
this tweet sucks because and it was
featured on the show so they know hey
hey you [__] idiot I showed your your
[__] tweet and I made fun of it so
come at me they hardly ever do because
they're a bunch of [__] snowflakes
but I I try to give them the heads up
that we mock them right right and she
says this at the end let me read it
again I don't have anything to hide I
just love my country and the people and
know how much they've been screwed over
by the government
in our government and I'm not willing to
be quiet about it
or willing to go along with it okay
right so she sounds like she's talking
about deep state right
right beef on the FBI she's got [__]
shirts that say that [__] right yeah
yeah am I correct
he has the fund the FBA defund FBI is
what it says that Define the FBI okay so
here is here is Marjorie Taylor Green's
proof that your TV Gabe Sanchez your TV
can be hacked are you ready oh no this
is it CBS News your smart TV might be
hacked by you listen listen listen
the FBI warns
is the FBI still watching me they are
still watching and they are still
warning that they're watching even
though you hate them and you want to
defund them the person who has defund
the FBI shirts
is using the FBI's warning that your
smart TV may be spying on you but you're
also getting this from a woman who does
not know how to read so she says she
says or she reads it and goes hackers
she saw some headlines like hackers uh
can take over your TV she's like that's
all I needed and she [__] tweeted it
and she put it in there as a comment as
another tweet did not read that it says
FBI FBI says right FBI says why do we
need the FBI why do we need the FBI we
need to defund it there it's the Deep
State it's weaponization of government
oh here here's a study by them that that
proves what I'm saying I'm gonna I'm
gonna use the FBI as my source you're a
[__] idiot in the same tweet where
you're saying the Deep State's coming
after you come on man
come on man
exists can't be real life can it yeah I
mean it's
it's something she's crazy man she's
[__] crazy
that's for sure you know what do you
think do you think that her boyfriend
from rsbn Brian Glenn yeah is real like
do you think that
they were to get do you think that they
were together
when when the TV thing happened or do
you think that she was alone and then
she called up Brian Glenn and she's like
oh my God honey you won't believe what
just happened the TV turned itself on
and the woman from The Ring came out and
she tried to choke me
and it seems like there's a video in
there somewhere yeah you ain't got to
another hour right not another hour okay
okay okay all right all right let's
let's move on I want to make fun of
Marjorie Taylor green some more but
let's move on we'll move on okay let's
go to the dishonorable mention the
supremist Court the supremacist Court
excuse the premises the supremacist
Court I feel like that could be its own
show which is real life right uh you
know it's like dum-dum you know it's
like a lawn it's like a Law and Order
and it's like this week on the
supremacist Court which that might be a
video there too I mean it's been a kind
of all week yeah and I think we knocked
it out of the park
um I'm gonna leave it up to you uh I
mean there's nothing really else to say
outside of the fact that uh well there
was an there was one new thing that we
could mention
um actually the one with Mississippi's
Jim Crow era loss yeah yeah yeah okay so
I haven't read much about it I just saw
the tweet
let me let me um Let me let me show it
to you here now
um as you know in our country uh to make
sure that um black people can't vote as
much what they do is they say oh you're
a felon and you've had felony
convictions in the past you can't vote
ever in the history of ever even though
you paid your dues and you paid your
time now some states have done away with
this Missouri is one of them for all you
wondering out there because they always
tweet that [__] at me oh can you even
vote Yes Missouri dummy go look the
[__] mob you [__] idiot some
states have done away with this where if
you have a felony on your record if you
paid your dues and you've paid your time
then you can re-register to vote and you
can vote in this country because it's
one of the nailable rats
right actually I believe that um felons
in prison should be able to vote too
they're in this country they're living
off the government in the prison so they
should be able to vote for the
representatives that are voting and
passing laws
for their existence side prison yeah I
said it I said it and I'll keep saying
it people in prison should be able to
vote [__] you if you don't like it leave
it if you don't love it leave it you
think you think you can just decide
which ones are enable and who is enable
and not [__] you yeah um and you're from
another country living in another
country like Ian miles Chong and you
decide to comment on our politics about
different candidates
I'm super excited when you're able to
vote here I just can't wait for the next
election right and I'll see you at the
[__] polling place right right there
bright and early right I want you to
document it I can't wait I can't wait
for you to vote all the way from
Malaysia
so here's the Democracy docket has this
breaking news that says U.S Supreme
Court declines to review Mississippi's
Jim Crow era law that strips the right a
vote for life from individuals with a
certain felony convictions the 1890 law
will remain in place disenfranchising
tens of thousands of mississippians so
what the challenge was to the Supreme
Court is to overturn and get rid of this
[__] where if you had a felony
conviction that you can actually vote
and decide what happens to your state
and your [__] Community because
you're a part of it it's really
ridiculous that we think that people who
have had felony convictions shouldn't
participate in their [__] Community
it's dumb as dog [__] and then wonder
why oh why why why do so many people go
go back to prison after they've been in
prison why did so many felons end up
getting copying other felony convictions
it's because of this because you make
them second-class citizens it's because
you make them outcasts you make them the
fringes of society which then they they
they just take advantage of get them
engaged in their communities make them
part of the communities that they live
in you [__] idiots yeah yeah they
made a mistake yeah they paid for it
yeah so they should be able to
participate now that they've given their
debt and again I'm gonna just go as far
as say people being locked up should
[__] definitely have the right to
vote 100 yeah [__] you you don't like
that yeah that's what that's what uh
what was it just a few years ago right
in Florida
uh there was this this this uh was it
the case I'm trying to remember exactly
I don't want to misspeak but basically
was on giving giving felons the right to
vote in the State of Florida right and
Republicans being obviously afraid that
those people yeah that were in prison
right or got out of prison would vote a
certain way and that way being
Democratic right or definitely not
Republican another good point from Craig
here in the chat and if we can find the
comment I'll pull it up if someone's
sending me this
um Craig says why can't people in prison
vote but they can run for president
I just I just thought that's a good
question it's kind of convenient yep
maybe you people out there who don't
want felons to vote ever for the rest of
their life shouldn't want felons running
for president or Congress do you know do
you know that there's a shitload of
members of Congress who are felons
shitload did you know Donald byrons is a
former felon I did not know that yeah
is
Republicans not I mean not not that it
makes a difference to me I don't give a
[__] I I don't like his policies [__]
him being a felon I could care less if
he's a felon his policies are absolute
trash right you're right I mean it
doesn't change like just because you're
a feloner that you went to prison you
did your time doesn't take away that
like
you can or you should be able to
exercise your inalienable rights and the
fact that we take it away from you is
pretty [__] up
uh and the fact that even after you do
your time right you serve your time you
agree by you know probation or going to
jail or whatever it is right that is
like yeah you still you know what you're
still not good in RI and now
understandably so you're gonna have a
chip on your shoulder and you're not
going to trust us and you're going to be
very skeptical and we're never going to
give you that right back to choose
because you don't agree you obviously
uh don't agree with the people that put
you there
in the laws that were put in place and
God forbid you want to exercise your
right to change those laws
but but they they you know Republicans
fear that very thing and that's why they
don't want to give those rights back to
people who come out of prison in jail
[__] no [__] no and and to give you full
disclosure yes I vote in the state of
Missouri and I have my voting rights
back after being in prison I have my
voting rights back because I if you're
out there wondering and you always tweet
at me you [__] morons yes because I
served my time in the Missouri state law
unlike this Mississippi Law which is a
bunch of [__] and there's punting on
it because they don't want to make the
decision
because they know what the [__]
decision is is it is a right that you
should have if you paid your debt
Society again like Craig said
like Craig said if you can [__] if
you can run from president from prison
as a [__] felon then you goddamn
right you should be able to vote so if
your stance is that Donald Trump should
be able to run for president even though
he's con he's charged and indicted and
possibly convicted by the time he's
running for president United States
and maybe even in prison for those
felonies then you goddamn right you
goddamn right people in prison should
[__] vote so get on the right track
you [__] speaking about being
on the right track what is this Alpha
cook thing because you change this on me
yes I did he changes what is it I don't
I don't know I don't know this story all
right so click on the video click on the
first link that I sent you well let me
start here the alpha duck is uh tell us
tell us about the alpha cook here all
right so Miami Seaquarium right so this
was actually what is what is the
Seaquarium is this like a Sea World type
thing yeah it's kind of it's like a it's
a a spot in Miami that's like it's a
it's kind of like a Sea World kind of
thing right and they got this so it's a
tourist attraction like people go there
and yeah yeah it's a place where you can
go and you can uh I I don't I don't I
honestly I this is the first time I've
ever heard of this so oh okay okay well
yeah I mean I know I know that these
things exist I'm just saying yeah I
don't I didn't know about this
particular story yeah it's just it's
just one of the like it's another like
Marine Mammal Park kind of places they
have exhibits and people can show up and
watch and you know it's just like
[__] Sea World kind of thing right so
the reason it's such a big deal
um and it was actually Dara that brought
it up um she did it some she had some
tweets about it and I actually I send
them to you because I want to play the
video because she does a good a job of
summarizing what happened today in the
chat I see her I see her I see you
talking [__] and
but but basically uh so there was a
company that took over right uh this
Miami Seaquarium so it was sold or it
was done yeah it was a transfer there
was a transfer of ownership
um and Derek can correct me wrong but
from what I gather there was a transfer
of ownership and they agreed that they
were going to release this Orca named
Lolita right and uh this Orca has been
in the tank since 1970 or something like
that and so this this Orca has been in
Camp in case it's been in captivity from
for its entire life yes yeah yeah and uh
it's been in the same tank and it hasn't
been released even though they promised
that they would release the Orca and
then not only that but the tank at
itself hasn't been cleaned it's it's uh
it's gross dirty uh it's un it's just
not healthy right if you're imagine like
oh I'm an orca and I'm in the [__]
ocean in the ocean is a large space
where I can get fresh water right uh
well the opposite is I'm stuck in a pool
and no one's [__] cleaning this [__]
and I can't clean it myself right
so that's like the quick and dirty of
this all right pull up these two videos
here
let me see if I can so this is aerial
footage this is Drone footage of the
tank that Orca the uh Lolita the Orca is
in
okay so this is this is um
and so this group urgencies
is exposing and you click on the other
one and I think it's more of a Time
Lapse video here's a Time Lapse video of
the uh
so as you can imagine
like it's one not a huge space for an
orca right and not only that but it's
it's dirty it's it's it's it's it's
[__] filthy filthy water right so
scroll down
and this is uh
[Music]
uh her and her her threads yeah all
she's got oh they blocked me they
blocked her because she brought it up
she has a simple question of like why
the [__] is it there anyway so this is
the video that dare put together this is
one of them because there's also an
update after
okay well let's uh oh so there's a
there's another video all right let's
watch let's watch this one here I'm not
an org
an orphan region thought that I was I
don't know what's wrong with you how
Free Willy enough times to know that
well I don't ever want to put ketchup on
a cake and eat it and also that the the
tank shouldn't look like this so urgency
is posted a video and I'm about to show
you a clip of Lolita which is an orca at
the Miami
Seaquarium in I assume Miami Florida
[Music]
[Applause]
Lolita has been in this tank since 1970
and alone in it since 1980. she's
supposed to be released it'll happen I
guess what happens I know a lot of it's
complicated to release an orca and
return them to like the Pacific
Northwest or wherever they go although
now I'm thinking they might want to
start guarding the areas around the
Titanic for funsies however my
subscriptions have been raised because I
I posted this tweet today
you could pause to read that's that's
the one we just read suspicious mother
efforts went ahead and blocked me
so
I don't know
feel free to inundate Miami Seaquarium
with questions about why they won't
clean the orcas goddamn tank
thank you for coming to my TED Talk
[Laughter]
so if you if you now click on the second
video right
um I'm not an orca expert if the second
video the second link that I sent you oh
okay so there's hey right so when I was
doing it when I was doing a bit of
research something that I discovered was
that this aquarium from it's owned by
another group that's called Ms Leisure
okay and Ms Leisure took over
um the park not not too long ago uh and
and they they're actually owned by
another company called the dolphin
company which is headquartered in Cancun
Mexico maybe they know Ted Cruz which
operates 32 aquatic Parks habitats and
marinas generating about 40 million
dollars in annual revenue according to a
memo from the county chief operations
officer Jamie Morales now in in this I
also discovered that they have
uh
other there's uh from the the USDA which
is the US Department of Department of
Agriculture they had a warning of
alleged violations the handling of
animals on July 6th uh another violation
of handling animals on July 6. this is
2022.
deprivation of food or water uh during
public exhibition any animal must be
handled uh mishandling of animals right
another violation on July 6 2022
attending veterinarian and Aquatic
Veterinary Care they weren't
another violation on January 6th uh
attending Veterinary veterinary care and
Aquatic Veterinary Care again violating
the fact that there are mishandling
they're not feeding them well they're
not cleaning they're not they're not
doing all of the Just bare minimum to
help make sure that these uh aquatic
animals exist right bare minimum and
they took over and they made these
agreements and they said they were going
to do this stuff and they didn't do it
and one of and yes and as Edward points
out this is this next video that we're
gonna pull up right and they're saying
that they're suing the guy who shot the
footage for defamation
what's this group's name again Open Seas
Open Seas Leisure something like that no
no no no no sorry the group the group of
the original I want to know that who's
suing who for definition okay Ms Leisure
company
suing okay this person who shot the
Drone footage for defamation which is
owned by the dolphin company hey EMASS
Leisure hey if you're listening I'll
give anyone a voice on my show to come
after your dumb ass how about that
defamation you [__] pieces of garbage
okay let's let's listen to the second
video here
um the darmi the man who captured the
Drone footage for urgencies has been
served with a lawsuit brought to him by
Miami Seaquarium here's the civil action
summons you can you can pause to read
if you're confused let me catch you up
to speed urgencies took Drone footage
above the Orca tanks at the Miami
Seaquarium to show what the conditions
for Lolita their Orca is and Miami's
aquarium did not like that Miami
Seaquarium is now the victim so amongst
all the different things that they are
trying to bring about in this lawsuit
defamation is one of them and we're
going to focus on that right now they're
claiming that Phil
um damaged their reputation this is
beyond laughable I have to assume Miami
lawyer John Ruiz is representing Miami
Sea Aquarium because look at this
article here from May 23 2022. it says
here that beginning in 2017 the
Seaquarium began losing revenue and
ticket sales plummeted to less than 500
000 annually remember in those
defamation suits you gotta you gotta
prove a loss of profits but I think I
think it could all get proven in the
whole anti-slap laws that Florida has
what do I know attorney I just
play one on the internet anyway I don't
think Phil is the one damaging Miami
seaquarium's good name since they've
kind of done it themselves because
they've kept their whale in captivity
since 1970 despite her like tank mate
unaliving herself in 1980 and people
have been calling for her release since
then but good luck in that in that
lawsuit Miami Seaquarium I hope you
don't Streisand affect yourself with all
this
so basically the in these core documents
um that that Dara sent me
um there's a there's the man who
captured the Drone footage yeah yeah so
uh in these court documents some of the
complaints that they're making right so
they're they're uh they're suing the
defendant which is still Demers okay
um and this is the guy you do the Drone
footage yeah this is the guy that did uh
the Drone footage if anyone has contact
with him uh get him in contact with me
yeah yeah we'll have him on the show
yeah let's get him on the show um but
some of some of the of the things are
trespassing the plaintiff re-alleges and
incorporates paragraphs one to 23 a
bunch of [__] trespassing he went on
their property I don't think that's
right but that's also assuming that so
there's also this case that they're
trying to make which is saying you
trespass by shooting Drone footage but
the the aquarium doesn't own the
airspace
I'm just saying that it's almost like I
don't know the government owns the space
that is above a certain amount of feet
in the air in which you would say oh
yeah that's that's our property so it's
almost like it's almost like the Drone
wasn't on their property is that what
you're saying yeah it was not on their
property at all
um and again it's it's why you might
have you know
uh an agency around Aviation uh that
works for the government that creates
the laws as to where you can find where
you can fly and you as a private entity
a company you can't say that they were
trespassing uh and it said the defendant
willfully entered and remained on
properties by way of flying his drone
over open aired congregations of people
and above several animal disclosures
with uh which were not accessible to the
public
and then in addition it says count two
private nuisance plaintiff that's
[__] [__] 123 without any
authorization of the plaintiff defendant
wrongfully flew a drone over the
plaintiff's property again you don't own
the property and you don't own the
airspace I as someone who just owns as a
just a [__] recreational drone owner
and flyer like I know what I can and
can't do and uh you don't own the rights
to say that you can't fly over I mean
that's that's what it is now the
government can tell you this is a no-fly
zone yeah the government can say hey
you're too close because because they
control what what do they control and
then the airspace oh okay is that
probably why they do that is so that
they control the airspace and not the
individual Property Owners because this
would be like you saying as a farmer I
don't want any commercial airlines going
over my farm and I don't care if it's
ten thousand feet thirty thousand feet
forty thousand feet you can't fly over
my farm because that's my property yeah
you see how ridiculous that sounds
it sounds [__] ridiculous man it's
pretty it's pretty crazy do you think
that's the [__] that's the [__]
that's the [__] I mean that's that's
what they think they think that because
well they're playing the victim and they
say oh man we got caught [__]
mistreating this Orca and now what we're
gonna do is we're gonna play victim and
say that oh we were the actual ones who
were who were traumatized and we were
them and then of course you know what I
got a suggestion I got a suggestion for
Ms Leisure here how about you instead of
spending money on lawyers to do stupid
[__] lawsuits spend that money on
cleaning the [__] tank you despicable
pieces of [__] how about that how about
that huh how about that defamation come
on c d bring it here I'll give you the
[__]
address to send it to
I'll tell you like I tell every other
person that tries to sue me [__] you
then they go for defamation they go for
defamation they go for uh that's
hilarious uh they go for violation of a
Florida statute uh which is they say
that again it's this whole thing of like
they own the private property and you
can't fly the drone over and then their
injunctive relief which
they spelled [__] relief wrong man
I'm looking at this thing right here and
it says injunctive relief r-e-l-e-i-f
it happens this is what happens when you
deal with people who think that they
know more than you and that when they
get busted
for mistreating and going back on a
promise they made and then say Oh no I'm
the victim how dare you
what do you expect their lawyer [__]
misspells words in here
and I don't know what injunctive relief
is because I've never heard relief
spelled r-e-l-e-i-f so technically
that's not a legal thing so they can go
[__] themselves that's that's the that's
what happens when the leaf gets back up
in the tree
um Tracy says here
Dar is a rock star I love her and I
don't know if she's still in the chat I
don't see her anywhere so she wasn't
yeah she might be creeping she might
have mine she might have left you creep
you creepo um but if you didn't leave
thank you for the videos thank you for
the story I'm glad that Gabe pulled an
audible and did this story because I
would love I would love this I would
love
for whoever this is Ms Leisure whoever
owns this to come after me that'd be
great let's do that I think I think me
and all the Orca lovers out there would
[__] win so do it do it do it and go
after that drone and and if anyone has
contact with the Drone operator yeah get
him in contact with me I want to talk to
this [__] I want to talk to him
and I want to have them on the show uh
let's get back we got we got it we're
damn we're we're gonna go three hours
you ain't got a choice okay uh bonehead
of the week winner we know who it is is
Donald Trump of course he was on the
pole and with uh marjor Taylor green and
Tommy to Tommy Tommy two branches and he
thinks there's two branches Tommy two
branches
um but Donald Trump is dumber than Tommy
tuberville that's [__] ridiculous
that Donald Trump is more bone-headed
than Marjorie Taylor green the dumbest
well in competition for the dumbest
member of Congress and then Tommy I mean
definitely the dumbest member of the
Senate I mean uh it's it it's hard I
mean well I will say in in the Twitter
poll it was close between
um was it I think it was hold on who ran
away with it and was it the YouTube that
made it it was YouTube it was like 76
YouTube [__] hates trump our YouTube
audience [__] hate Trump yeah it they
were really they really got a problem
they gotta he really I think I think our
audience got tired of March winning so
yeah it was 43 yeah 21 okay 35 on
Twitter that's close that was pretty
close that's the closest trump it was
pretty close right uh I mean they're all
like 12 to 13 points off and then on
YouTube it was 76. God damn 7 17. oh
[__] not even though that's kind of what
happened I mean if it wasn't for that 76
there could have been a chance that
tuberville could have could have ran
away with it if he if he had uh done
well on YouTube well I don't know
there's a thousand reasons why this gay
he just keeps he keeps climbing dude he
keeps criming he keeps admitting yes
there's a [__] statement right here
and just in the last hour where he's
saying stupid [__] but I want to show
this Cliff I haven't even seen it and I
want to show it it's 16 seconds of him
and Kerry Lake I don't know if they just
got done or what oh they're totally
doing it
[Laughter]
oh [__]
[Music]
so you know what you know what you know
small rats is gonna make a [__]
reason
Donald Trump and Carrie like
barrettes in the
she's like oh I'm on it [__] I want
Tony to play that [__] yeah
I mean there's there's a clip of Donald
Trump where he's like
there's multiple ones where he does that
and then there's the other one he's like
I'm gonna come
oh my God
oh this is gross I don't even know what
happens in this clip but we're gonna
watch it uh you're welcome for the um um
the last minute uh Carey Lake Donald
Trump whatever the hell this is gonna be
before the vacation here you go
[Applause]
[Music]
what the [__] is this she's got a new
book is that what this is
laughs
she does have a new book she's got a new
book I've seen photos and I've seen I've
seen uh I think it was on Patriot takes
it was uh let me see if I can find the
photo
it was somebody at Mar-A-Lago is it at
this event
yeah yeah yeah yeah is it the is it the
only place she's gonna sell these books
probably I wouldn't I I uh you know who
or oh actually you know who the
publisher is who it's the [__] uh God
damn it what uh
the one uh 45 books it's the [__]
winner whatever it's called uh it's
Donald Trump's Publishing Company the
wondering
about all the photos that he stole from
his photographer oh my God you can't
even actually get published as well I
mean you have to remember that all the
books that are under the 45 books or the
45 winning or whatever the [__] it's
called you have to remember that all of
those books one is Charlie Kirk's uh
education one where it's like don't go
to college this kind of thing and then
there's is that why is because that's
the only reason how the only way they
can get published is that yes they
started yes yes it is yes they're like
oh no one else will publishes also it's
because a way for them to Griff money
right they're going to take a percentage
of the deal as a clinical publisher and
all the people who are going to buy it
like if you had the RNC right the RNC
paid uh 90 to 100 K Plus on triggered
which was published through that
publishing company if I remember
correctly and that's the name of his
book and his podcast that he's triggered
not triggered and I wrote a book about
it and I have a podcast every [__]
week
triggered because I'm triggered winning
winning team publishing that's what it
is winning team publishing they even
have to project in the business names
that they yeah oh my God oh my God we're
gonna go to the website really quick I'm
just gonna send you the link so here's
that Patriot takes uh Carey Lake's book
inscription let's take a sledgehammer to
these commie bastards that's her signing
the book
is that the one you wanted to show me
and yeah
[Music]
let's let's take a sledgehammer to these
commy bastards you know what's funny
Carrie Lake used to be a Barack Obama
supporter did you know that [__] yeah
once in a long time she used to be vocal
against Donald Trump what she used to
hate Donald Trump now she's schlobbing
him yeah well she and her uh her alone
she she and the one from from uh
Utah Right whoa whoa whoa who no Wyoming
Wyoming yeah oh you're talking about
you're talking about the wish.com yeah
yeah she's the one that's her not using
the filter yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
the
yeah no joke look at a photo you'll see
it anyway uh if you go to the the
website I sent you 45 books 40 oh my God
judge [__] oh my God they're all on
here I didn't know she was on there too
amazing let's see
how to get American Jazz Janine Pirro
yeah we can't get published anywhere
else so we have to go go to the the menu
icon the hamburger menu icon menu I want
to scroll hey you don't yeah I'm gonna
show you all the products oh even Joel
Olsteen's in there no no no he's in the
he's in the light now he's in the letter
Book he wrote a letter to Donald Trump
go up go up go up go up I'm I'm getting
there what do you want shop shop them
all right there we go so we got the
signed copy the unsigned copy okay oh
God damn do you see that what the [__]
are you [__] me 300 bucks baby
he's drifting [__]
and then 29 and then it's only 20 bucks
for her yeah well yeah well I mean come
on and then let's see Terry Lake Carrie
Lake 20 bucks 20 bucks for her signature
oh my God and then go down
the college scam yeah oh his liberal
privilege that was the book sorry no
it's not triggered yeah 29 bucks did we
get a 49 copy signed
um oh no it's signs John Jr signing his
dad's photo book
199 how much is the original price of
this
um book before Don Jr signs it how much
does how much does Donald Trump think
that his son's signature's worth
you get that together what the [__] is
uh scroll up I want the [__] I know I
know I know I know I know where is that
oh God okay go back to the homepage go
back to the homepage hang on hang on
there it is there boom so how much was
it 99 199 so 125 bucks is what he thinks
Don Jr signature's worth I would love to
see how many people were like yeah I
need to get one signed by Don Jr and
leave some of that powder residue for me
later right is that does he sign it with
his uh
his uh Coke caked fingernails a little
bloody but here's Carrie Lake here's how
much Donald Trump thinks Carrie Lake's
signature is worth 20 bucks 20 bucks 20
bucks that's it that's all you're worth
you've [__] you [__] loser that's
what you are you are Kiri Lake and I'm
all right how does she sound I'm I'm
Carrie Lake and I'm unafraid
Lake are you unfiltered are you
unfiltered because it seems like you
you're filtered
hi I'm Carrie Lake and I'm unafraid
hi everyone I'm just telling you my
fellow Patriots that uh I'll be at
Mar-A-Lago with the big man
dunny
uh yeah now fellow Patriots I just want
to tell you that I love you so much so
make sure to give me your money uh just
give give me your money okay okay
oh my god oh that's it that's bone end
of the week I'm really sorry that it
took forever to get there and
let's give Donald Trump
his due
[Music]
[Applause]
Donald Trump seems to be unafraid
I don't know
why I can't stop oh my God oh my God if
you think he's unafraid just go to his
true social page and read a few of them
he
terrified
absolutely losing his Mind Over Georgia
because uh Brad rathus Mathis pathos
Mathis Burger
um was interviewed by Jack Smith and
Fanny Fanny Willis is on his heels
everyone
Donald Trump is not the bone of the week
he's a Bonet of the century but this has
been bone end of the week stick around
we got a few announcements don't go
anywhere
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
end of the week I'm glad you stuck
around for a whole hour you know yeah
somebody was like oh get uh I do have to
take a phone call though uh but somebody
was like Tony I think Tony uh
uh uh tricked you into doing 300 I did
me
you kept going on about the Carrie Lakes
definitely
all right take your phone call take your
phone call I'll do the announcements
from here and I get the hell out of here
have a good vacation
have a have a good vacation bye everyone
don't don't do what I would do do the
opposite of this yeah but I have some
fun have some fun we'll see you next
Thursday
yeah [__] Cheapskate on the cheap
skating on time I thought you had to
take a phone call I am I am I would just
leave okay bye get the hell out of here
all right see ya all right everybody uh
I'm gonna make a few announcements for
you remember next Monday Tuesday
Wednesday we're off the air uh for
Fourth of July I want you guys to have a
safe holiday I want you to celebrate
with your family your friends I want you
to have fun
um and I want you to engage in your
democracy while you're doing it make
sure you bring up what is going on in
our country and make sure that you have
the proper strategic outrage
um that you need to have when you're
talking to folks I'm telling you you're
not going to run into a line of
opposition on some of these Supreme
Court decisions they're not you're
you're just not they're not going to
find a lot of people that
are on the side of fascism here no
matter where you live in the country so
go out there have a great holiday be
safe please be safe with with fire
firecrackers firecrackers uh I got one
one more video I want to show you here
um uh speaking of firecrackers and the
reason why is because I found this video
and I thought you know what this is
[__] perfect
let's see if I can pull it up here
um when it comes to like firecrackers
and stuff because I know a lot of people
uh
what the hell hang on hang on let me get
it let me get it I haven't glitch in
here here we go
um I'm gonna turn the sound off on this
because I want to talk over it so here
is these are drones we were talking
about drones earlier flying over the uh
the tank of Lolita the the Orca where
they need to clean the [__] tank and
not be scumbags but these are drones
look how [__] awesome this is this is
[__] really cool
this is so awesome and
um maybe maybe in the future we can get
past burning [__] down to the ground and
using fireworks I like fireworks I like
the big Kabooms and stuff but some
people don't but this is this is pretty
[__] amazing if you want to know the
truth with drones and lights
um and it does some wild [__] here at
the end so maybe maybe just maybe
um
beautiful things are in our future with
technology everyone wants to get crazy
with technology they get they get all
pissed off about technology but
um in some in some respects technology
is beautiful
and it the future is not something to be
scared of it's something to watch it's
something to protect
um and we must protect it in our
democracy
and we must protect our Liberty and we
must protect our rights because if we do
that we will protect everyone's equality
everyone's equity and everyone's Liberty
in this country that is what
individualism actually brings to us when
everyone has individual liberty we all
do and we must not forget this on the
fourth of July as we go into the Fourth
of July so
yeah everyone's saying that's cool as
[__] it is pretty [__] cool
it's pretty [__] cool you're right
Amanda it is cool as [__]
um and this is not fireworks this won't
set your house on fire or blow your
eyeball out
um
but it's pretty [__] cool so I wanted
to show you guys that as we go for the
holiday thanks for joining us here on
the Tony Michaels podcast don't forget
to subscribe to the YouTube channel
you're not going to want to miss a
single thing especially when we come
back next Thursday
again
we won't be on the air Monday Tuesday
Wednesday I know you guys want to have
the show here's what you do
you subscribe to the YouTube channel
right don't forget to subscribe here to
the YouTube channel and at the exact
time that we usually go to the air go
back and find your favorite episode and
play that episode during that time
that's what I suggest a lot of people
like put together a best thing
I am just one dude you know how many
hours I talk every single day you know
how I need a whole team of producers and
editors to do a best of so go back find
your favorite episode between now and
then your favorite three episodes that
is and play those on Monday Tuesday
Wednesday and really you could do that
during the weekend I know a lot of
people
um want to hear the the my voice on the
weekend and you get excited about the
patreon Rants and stuff
um but you know if you're feeling down
or something you need that motivation to
engage in your democracy go watch your
favorite episode from the week really
truly or you can download the episode on
Apple's Spotify Google you can download
it and listen to the audio version which
you should be that helps out the show
every single weekday
you should be downloading those episodes
you can watch it on Facebook you can
re-watch it on Facebook if you're over
there next week Monday Tuesday Wednesday
just find that favorite episode on
Facebook repost it re-share it somewhere
and then re-watch it at the same exact
time so go to Facebook and search at the
Tony Michaels follow us there you can
also watch on Twitch and you can
re-watch they don't stay there forever
on Twitch but you can re-watch some of
them so go follow us on twitch.tv Tony
Michaels don't forget over the weekend
also we've had a lot of people that
haven't re-subscribed with their Prime
account over on Twitch don't forget you
just you just go to you just go to
thetonymichaels.com that's D Tony
michaels.com and you will find the
directions there on how to link your
Amazon Prime account to your Twitch
account to give us that one free
subscription but don't forget to
re-subscribe every month
you got to do whatever when they give us
free money they don't make it easy but
it is pretty easy and the reason why is
because our great mod the mighty
librarian has given you directions on
how to link your account and how to
resubscribe to the Tony Michaels podcast
on Twitch so just go to the Tony
michaels.com it's the fourth link down
make sure you don't forget to
resubscribe on Twitch
for that free couple bucks that Prime
and Amazon gives us that doesn't cost
you a single nickel and also don't
forget pride month right right Pride
right we've got pride month going on so
go to
store.donymichaels.com that's stored at
Eagle and tonymichaels.com use the promo
code Pride to get your pride merch or
any merch yeah you can tell Ron DeSantis
to go [__] himself you can say Surf's Up
[__] you can say the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people is
not Liberty you can say let them eat
rake at store.the tonymichaels.com just
use the promo code Pride you'll get 15
off your entire purchase you are the
best audience in the world I hope you
have a safe
and and friendly and exciting holiday
weekend I will see you next Thursday
live
here same time same place happy Fourth
of July Surf's Up [__] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's muleborn headass Beacon
I'm your wife
[Music]
paint it through this message
thank you